أكبر عامل مسبب أو مرتبط بالإصابة بالسرطان هو التقدم في العمر
نشوف عند النساء اللي عندهم سرطان رحم
نسبة كبيرة منهم هم نساء سمينات
وجود السرطان ليس بالضرورة أن علاجه كيمائي وعلاجه معقد
ممكن فيه علاجات بسيطة له؟
99% من الحالات يمكن تفاديها
الحرمة الفرنسية أتوقع اللي عمّرت عمرها 117 سنة
وكانت تدخن إلى أن ماتت يمكن وأكلها عادي
وهي أكثر واحدة معمّرة
هذه أكبر من أكبر المغالطات
حبيبي!
اللي عند الناس لما نشوف المعمّرين؛ أنه نشوف أسلوب حياتهم
عند النساء المعمرات نسبة التدخين أعلى من المعدل الطبيعي
فمعناته التدخين صحي!
معناته التدخين صحي، صح؟!
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
هذه الحلقة ما بنتكلم كيف تطوّل عمرك
مو عشان غير مهمة وغير ممكن
لكن لأن هذا الموضوع أهم
وهذا الموضوع في يدنا نتحكم فيه
هو كيف تعيش عمرك بأفضل صحة حتى مع تقدمك في السن؟
فلعيش حياة صحية أطول فترة ممكنة
فيه حاجتين نركز عليها
السلوكيات الوقائية اللي تقينا من الأمراض القاتلة والشيخوخة
فمن هذه السلوكيات: التغذية ونوع الأكل
والرياضة وتحديد أنواع الرياضات
اللي تساعد في الوقاية من هذه الأمراض
كذلك المكملات الغذائية، اللي ضيفي وضع دليلًا شاملًا لها
رغم أنه يشوف أثرها قليل مقارنة بالأكل والرياضة والنوم
وبعد سلوكيات الوقاية تكلم عن الثاني اللي هو الأمراض نفسها
هذه الأمراض اللي تسبب الوفيات لمعظم البشرية
فالناس تموت بالدرجة الأولى من أمراض القلب والشرايين
ومن ثم السرطان وبعدها الأمراض الأيضية
فما هي أمراض القلب؟ وما هي أسبابه؟
ومتى يكون التدخل سلوكي أو دوائي؟
والأهم كيف أكشف عنه؟ وأعرف أن عندي هذه الأمراض في أقرب وقت ممكن؟
كذلك السرطان اللي أهم شيء هو ممكن يخلي الوفيات تقل
أننا نكشف بدري، الكشف مبكرًا
يخلي معظم الحالات السرطانية قابلة للشفاء منها بشكل سهل
ودائمًا يرتبط الكبر في السن مع الخرف والزهايمر
فكيف نتعامل مع الأمراض العصبية؟
هذه الحلقة مهمة لكل أحد دون استثناء
هذه الحلقة مع ضيفي الدكتور «آدم بطاينة»
طبيب مختص بالأمراض الباطنية والأورام ومهتم بأمراض الشيخوخة
قبل أن نبدأ
تهتم ثمانية بإنتاج محتوى متنوع
هذا المحتوى يؤثر في حياتك ويضيف لمعارفك
ومن أشكال هذا المحتوى النشرات البريدية
أنتجنا في ثمانية حتى الآن نشرات في مجالات متنوعة
يعمل على كل نشرة فريق شغوف، مهمته
أن يكتب لك محتوى مثري وممتع ومجاني
وهدفه أنك تبقى على اطلاع بالمجال اللي يهمك
فمثلًا تلقى نشرة سينمائية للأفلام، ونشرة «إلخ» للكتب
ونشرة «أها» اليومية اللي تحاول أنها تقدم بديل صحي
للتصفح العشوائي على الإنترنت
أو نشرة فنجان، أفضل نشرة بريدية وبقية النشرات
اطّلع على وصف كل نشرة
في الرابط الموجود في وصف هذه الحلقة
وقبل البداية، الشكر لراعي الحلقة
شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن لنبدأ
فيه حلقة سويتها، و«معاذ» يقول: أنها غيرت حياته، قال لك عليها؟
لا
أيوة حكى لي عن «عمار» صح، حكى لي
تتفق معه؟
مع أنه ما حضرت الحلقة كاملة
بس «عمار» بشكل عام كنت أتفق معاه أكثر زمان
بس قل اتفاقي معه مع الوقت
كثير ما يتفقوا معه
هو بتعرف فيه الناس اللي بيمشوا على حمية «الكيتو»
بحس لازم يكون فيه مسمى للناس اللي مشيت على حمية «الكيتو»
وخرجت من الجانب الآخر
لأنه ما بترجع نفس الشخص قبل ما تدخل حمية «الكيتو»
أيش تقصد لأني ما فهمت؟
قصدي بيصير عندك وعي أكثر عن هذا الموضوع
بس بتصير عادي تاكل كربوهيدرات وبتاكل سكر
بس بيصير عندك وعي أكثر عن الموضوع
بحس هذه شغلة جيدة، جيد الواحد يجرب حمية «الكيتو»
ويدخل بهذا العالم شوي، بعدين يخرج من الجهة الأخرى
متوازن أكل
بس «عمار» ماله علاقة بـ«الكيتو» ترى
«عمار» فكرته أنك تاكل طبيعي فقط
هذا إذا بلخص كل اللي يقوله
أنه ما أدري أيش تبغى تاكل؟
تبغى تاكل كثير، تبغى تاكل قليل
الموضوع ما يخصني، بكيفك
بس أنا أبغاك تاكل كل شيء طبيعي
لا تأكل ولا أي شيء مصنع أو مكرر
هذه فكرة ببساطة
تبدأ من الملح إلى السكر، وكل شيء
هذه مفترض أي شيء مو طبيعي لا تأخذ
أحس أن تتفق معه
أيوة أكيد تتفق معه 100%
أنا بحب أكون أكثر يعني كم نسبة البروتين؟ كم نسبة كذا؟
بحب أحط قواعد وبروتوكولات
جزء منها يمكن مش كثير عملي، بس جزء منها هو بس اهتمام
كيف الواحد يهتم بشغلة معينة، بيصير يعرف كل تفاصيلها
طبعًا فيه برضه «فيصل سعود»
«فيصل» يهمه البروتين، بس يهمه تقلل سعراتك الحرارية
أيش تاكل؟ ما يهمه
تبغى تاكل آيسكريم، تبغى تاكل كبسة، تبغى بورقر؟ اللي تبغاه
بببسي
أتفق معاه أكثر شوي
تتفق أكثر؟
أيوة، وهذه الشغلة غيرت رأيي عنها مؤخرًا
خليني أحكي خلال آخر كم سنة
أهمية السعرات الحرارية، لأن تقريبًا المحصلة النهائي لكل الحِميات
هي التحكم بسعرات حرارية مع نوعية جيدة من الأكل
فأتفق أكثر مع «فيصل»
«فيصل»؟ «فيصل» أسهل، بس أحس أنه مو بصحي
وللا؟
هي ثلاث أشياء ممكن تتحكم فيها
نوعية الأكل، كمية الأكل، ووقت تناول الطعام
بالآخر أهم شغلة الكمية، وبعدين النوعية، وبعدين وقت تناول الطعام
بس الثلاثة أشياء مهمين
النوعية هي الأشياء الطبيعية وكمية البروتين العالية
الكمية بالآخر مهمة كثير
وبعدين وقت تناول الطعام يمكن له دور
توقعت أنك ما راح تتفق معاه، لأن «فيصل» يهمه أن تقلل السمنة
وهذا هدف واضح بالنسبة له
بس يمكن على المدى البعيد وعلى صحة المجتمع أكثر ضررًا
فكرة أنك تاخذ أشياء ماهي بصحية ومش طبيعية
أو حتى برضه المشروبات الغازية وغيره
بس أيهما أقرب؟ لأنك أنت ما بين الاثنين
مين الأفضل بالنسبة لإطالة العمر؟
أحس إن هذا اللي بيهمك أنت، صح؟
ما يهمك إذا أنا متين وللا لا، ما يهمك إذا آكل طبيعي وللا لا
يهمك التغذية وأثرها على الشيخوخة، صح كذا؟
بالنسبة لإطالة العمر، شغلة تحديد السعرات
هي كانت أول تدخل طبي أو مخبري
شافوه الخبراء أو الباحثين بيطيل عمر الفئران
ما بعرف إذا القصة صحيحة، بس بحكي لك
أن بالعشرينات من القرن الماضي كان فيه باحث عنده فئران
وكان عنده نقص بالأغذية تبع الفئران
فقرر يعمل تجربة
مجموعة قلل السعرات الحرارية عن حاجتها
والمجموعة الأخرى خلاها تاكل مثل ما تبغى
المجموعة اللي أكلت أقل؛ عاشت أطول
وهذا كان أول تدخل علمي بيطيل عمر الكائنات
فيه ناس مضادين لهذه الفكرة
بيحكوا أولًا أن هي التجربة خطأ، لأن هذه المجموعة أكلت زيادة
وهذه أكلت الطبيعي
وهذا الشيء مشابه لحالة الإنسان
احنا معظمنا بياكل كثير
وتقليل السعرات هو يمكن الشيء الطبيعي أكثر
بس تقليل السعرات 100% بيطيل عمر الكائنات
وبيقلل من الإصابة بالأمراض المزمنة 100% هذه شغلة مثبتة
بناخذ التغذية بشكل أكبر
بس الآن أيش اللي نبغاه من الحلقة؟
هل اللي أنت تبغاه أن يزيد عمر الإنسان؟ إطالة عمر الإنسان؟
وللا أن يعيش فترة أطول بصحة أفضل؟
الشغلة اللي أنا مهتم فيها
هي أيش الأشياء اللي ممكن نعملها اليوم
لنقلل من نسبة إصابتنا بالأمراض المزمنة
والأمراض المتعلقة بالتقدم في العمر مستقبلًأ؟
وهذا الشيء يتضمن كيف نقيس خطر إصابتنا بهذه الأمراض مستقبلًا
وأيش التدخلات اللي ممكن نعملها
لنقلل نسبة إصابتنا بهذه الأمراض مستقبلًا؟
طبعًا جزء منها التغذية والرياضة والأشياء هذه
بس فيه جزء أهم أو بنفس قدر الأهمية هي التدخلات الطبية
مثل الأدوية، الفحوصات الطبية اللي بنعملها
فهذا الجانب اللي أنا كثير مهتم فيه
أكثر حتى من التغذية والرياضة
لأن هذه تقريبًا أساسيات كلنا بنعرفها
بس فيه أشياء كثير مهمة غيرها، مش كثير معروفة عند الناس
بس لا، أتوقع أن هذه مو كثير بيعرفونها
وتوتر، أحس هذه توترني أكثر من التدخل الطبي
لأن التدخل الطبي أنا بروح لك، وأنت تشوف شغلك
هنا، أنت تبغاني أنا أشوف شغلي، وهذه طبيعة حياتي
أتوقع نمط الحياة حقي أنا اللي بتحكم فيه وهو اللي بيؤثر
بس أنت حكيت: أنا بروح لك
وهنا فيه مشكلة، أن الناس ما بتروح للطبيب
غير لما يصير عندها مشكلة
أكيد
ومعظم الأمراض المتعلقة بالتقدم بالعمر
أمراض القلب، الأمراض الأيضية
تبدأ كتغيرات بسيطة بالعشرينات والثلاثينات وتتراكم مع العمر
بعدين بتظهر على شكل أمراض في الخمسينات والستينات والسبعينات
هذا الشكل الطبيعي لتطورها
فمثلًا الناس اللي في العشرينات والثلاثينات
لما يتوفوا في حادث سيارة مثلًا
وبنشرّح أجسامهم؛ بتشوف بشرايينهم تغيرات بدائية
لمثلًا تصلب الشرايين اللي بيتراكم مع الوقت
وبيؤدي لأمراض القلب اللي هو المسبب الأول للوفاة عالميًّا
فهذه التغيرات بتبدأ بعمر صغير
فعشان كذا مهم أن نعرف احنا وين
ومهم أن تبدأ التدخلات الطبية، أنا برأيي مبكرًا
بس صدق أنه صعب
أيش تبغاني أسوي؟
كيف أعرف أن الشرايين عندي تمام، أروح أفحصها؟
أيوة بتقدر تعمل فحوصات
بس ليش أروح أفحصها وأنا في العشرينات؟ ما جاني شيء
فيه ناس ماتبي تروح المستشفى
بس مش شرط تروح على مستشفى أولًا
وثانيًا هي الفكرة أن تبدأ من عمر مبكر
يمكن العشرينات ما راح يكون عندك مشاكل
بس في الثلاثينات المفروض واحد يبدأ يفكر بهذه الطريقة
أن يعرف أول شيء الأساس تبعك وين
لأن فيه ناس عندهم استعداد جيني مثلًا لارتفاع الكوليسترول
هذا الشي بيبدأ في العشرينات، وبيكون موجود عنده في الثلاثينات
فحلو أن الواحد يعرف أن عنده هذه المشكلة من عمر مبكر
عشان يحلها مبكرًا
بس حتى الناس اللي ما عندهم مشاكل جينية
بالآخر احنا كلنا راح ننصاب بأمراض القلب
كلنا راح ننصاب بالنوع من أنواع المشاكل الأيضية مع التقدم في العمر
وبالآخر راح نموت من إحدى هذه الأسباب
كلنا؟
الغالبية العظمى راح نموت، أما من أمراض القلب والشرايين
السرطان، الأمراض الأيضية
الأيضية اللي هو؟
مثل السكري
عادةً هذه الأمراض بتؤدي للأمراض الأخرى اللي بنحكي عنها
اللي بتزيد نسبة الإصابة بأمراض القلب والشرايين
وكمان الأمراض العصبية، أمراض الدماغ
الفشل الكلوي، الأمراض الرئوية المزمنة
هذه كلها أسباب الوفاة اللي بتغطي يمكن 90% من حالات الوفاة
وأنت بالترتيب اللي قلته، اللي هو أمراض القلب هي أكثر شيء؟
أمراض القلب هي أكثر شيء
أكثر شيء تؤدي للوفاة؟
نعم
توقعت السرطان؟
لا، أمراض القلب
المهم هنا أن أمراض القلب والأمراض الأيضية مرتبطين ببعضهم
بيبدأوا بعمر مبكر جدًّا بالعشرينات والثلاثينات
بتبدأ التغيرات شوي شوي تتراكم
طيب لو بأجي الحين للعشرينات والثلاثينات
الآن كيف أعرف أن حياتي سيئة أو جيدة؟
أيش اللي مفروض أني أسويه الآن؟
أنت بالعشرينات؟
أنا بالثلاثينات، يلا قول لي
صدق لأنه يخوف، مثلًا واحد من الأصدقاء في الثلاثينات
أتوقع أنه أكبر مني بسنة أو أصغر مني بسنة
وجاته جلطة خفيفة الحمد لله عدت، بس في الدماغ
فما أعرف، هو صحته طيبة الصدق، ما تقدر تشوف أي شيء
فالحين أنا خايف، يلا طمني وقول لي أيش أسوي؟
أول شيء الواحد يبدأ يشوف مؤشرات اللياقة البدنية
اللي هي؟
اللي هي نبدأ بالأساس مثلًا الوزن
الوزن بالنسبة للطول، اللي هو مؤشر كتلة الجسم
هذه أساسيات، وبعدين ممكن بنشوف أكثر شوي بعمق
فهذه مفترض أنها تكون أيش؟
مفروض مؤشر كتلة الجسم عادةً أقل من خمسة وعشرين
من 18- 25 هو المكان الطبيعي
ولكن المشكلة بالوزن أنه بيتضمن
كل الأنسجة في جسمك: الدهون والعضلات
عشان كذا لازم نشوف شيء ثاني
اللي هو نسبة الدهون في الجسم
نسبة الدهون في الجسم مع كتلة الجسم
تعطيك صورة أوضح
لأن احنا نبغى مؤشر كتلة الجسم تبعنا يكون أقل من 25
لكن برضه نبغى الكتلة العضلية تكون مرتفعة
ونسبة الدهون تكون منخفضة
بتختلف بين النساء والرجال
كمان نظره أعمق فيه أنواع مختلفة من الدهون
فيه دهون ما تحت الجلد ودهون الحشوية
الدهون الحشوية هي الأخطر
هي الدهون بتكون بين الأعضاء، بتكون داخلة بين الخلايا
لما تشوف شخص عنده دهون حشوية مرتفعة
بتشوف مقطع من العضلات تبعهم
بيكون فيه دهون داخلة بين الخلايا العضلية
داخلة بين الأعضاء الداخلية مثل الكبد والبنكرياس
هذا الشيء بيأثر على وظائف هذه الأعضاء
وزن، نسبة الدهون، أنواع الدهون الحشوية وغير الحشوية
والدهون الحشوية هنا، أبغى أحكي عنها شوي
نبغى نحكي شوي عن الأمراض الأيضية لأنها كثير مهمة
مثلًا عملوا دراسة للناس البدينين والناس النحيفين
ووزعوهم بين وزن زائد مع دهون حشوية
وزن زائد بدون دهون حشوية
وزن منخفض مع دهون حشوية مرتفعة
وزن منخفض بدون دهون حشوية
وشافوا أن نسبة الأمراض بتزيد مع الدهون الحشوية المرتفعة
بغض النظر عن الوزن
الشخص النحيف وعنده دهون حشوية مرتفعة
مع أن وزنه طبيعي ومؤشر كتلة الجسم أقل من 25
بس كان عندهم نسبة الأمراض أعلى
من الناس اللي وزنهم مرتفع بس ما عندهم دهون حشوية
واو!
فهذا الشيء بيقول لك أن الوزن لحاله مش الصورة الكاملة
يبدو الموضوع معقد، لأن توقعت إذا هو نحيف ما عنده دهون حشوية
الدهون حشوية شلون؟ هل هي مسألة جينية وللا مسألة تغذوية وللا؟
هي مسألة جينية عند بعض الناس
بس برضه هي متعلقة إذا عندك كتلة عضلية منخفضة
مثلًا ما بتمارس الرياضة، ممكن يتجمع عندك دهون
بس بدون ما يكون عندك مؤشر كتلة الجسم عالي
اللي هم أحيانًا يسموهم «سكيني فات»
بتشوف ناس واضح عليه أن عنده دهون عالية
بس يمكن وزنه بشكل عام مش زايد
والتخلص منها بنوع معين من الرياضة وللا؟
التخلص منها عادةً تعمل إعادة بناء الأجزاء المختلفة من الجسم
يبغى لك تزيد الكتلة العضلية وتقلل الدهون
عن طريق رفع البروتين وزيادة ممارسة الرياضات
مثل رياضات القوة أو المقاومة
هذا الشيء بيرفع من الكتلة العضلية وبيقلل نسبة الدهون
لا بد أن يكون جزء منها تغذوي، بس برضه جزء كبير منها رياضي
كيف اكشف بهذه الدقة؟
هل هو هذا الجهاز اللي في الأندية اللي تمسكه؟
أيوة، هذا بيستخدم تكنولوجيا اسمها «المعاوقة الكهربائية الحيوية»
تيار كهربائي بيدخل في جسمك ويحلل بطريقة معينة
بس المعيار الذهبي مش هذا الفحص
المعيار الذهبي هو فحص نسميه «Dexa Scan»
اللي هو فحص بيستخدم الأشعة نفس أشعة صورة للصدر مثلًا
بس بيعطيك جرعة صغيرة من الأشعة تمشي على كل جسمك
ويستطيع الجهاز يعطيك نسبة الدهون
بدقة أعلى ونسبة الدهون الحشوية
فهذا الفحص اللي أنا بعمله مع بعض المرضى
بس فحص «إن بودي» أو «المعاوقة الكهربائية الحيوية»
فيه أجهزة منه دقتها أعلى شوي
من الأجهزة الموجودة عادةً بالأندية الرياضية
فممكن تستخدم كبديل
الحين عندنا الدهون أنت تقول...
بالمناسبة احنا هنا بنحكي عن مؤشرات اللياقة البدنية ولسه ما خلصناها
لسه فيه أشياء ممكن نعملها
فحوصات دم وفحوصات أخرى
فنحن لساتنا بس بالبداية
إيه، واضح أن الموضوع معقد
صدق هل احنا بنتكلم اليوم عن موضوع
الناس تقدر تسويه وللا هو فعلًا معقد بهذا الشكل عشان نعرف
قبل شوي أنت فتحت بس تبويبة صغيرة ودخلنا فيها
وشعرت بتعقيدها، هذا وباقي احنا بس لمسنا سطح المشكلة
ببساطة اللي ممكن نحكيه هو لازم نحافظ على وزن جيد ونلعب رياضة
يمكن أنا بحب أعقّد الأمور زيادة لأن أنا مهتم فيها
بس فيه ناس مهتمين أن يعرفوا تفاصيل التفاصيل
لا، نبغي نعرف التفاصيل، بس ودي أعرف...
أنا اللي بحكي عنه هو الحالة الأفضل مقابل الحالة الطبيعية
الحالة الطبيعية هو ممكن أنك بس تحافظ على وزن جيد
بس إذا حابب تاخذ كمان خطوة
حابب بجد تعرف وين أنت بالنسبة للصحة العامة
أنا بنصح أن الواحد ياخذ هذه الخطوات
فحكينا عن نسبة الدهون في الجسم ومؤشرات الوزن
بعدين ممكن نشوف مؤشرات اللياقة البدنية الأخرى
مثل: المرونة، الثبات والتوازن، الحركة الوظيفية أو التنقل الوظيفي
معليش مثل أيش؟
هذه عادةً تمارين بتعملها مع المدرب الرياضي
فيه حركات معينة حلو الواحد يقدر يعملها
وكيف الواحد يمرن هذه الشيء
عن طريق تمارين المرونة، تمارين التوازن
هذه من الأشياء المهملة شوي، ليش؟
لأن أول شيء مع العمر بتقل المرونة تبعنا
بتقل قدرتنا على الثبات والتوازن
هذا الشيء بيؤدي لأيش؟ للإصابات
من الأشياء اللي الناس كلها بتعرفها بعد ما يكبروا شوي بالعمر
بيبدأ الواحد يحس بآلام
آلام ركبة، آلام ظهر، مش عارف أيش
وجزء كبير من الإصابات هو لأن الثبات تبعنا منخفض
المرونة تبعنا منخفضة، التنقل الوظيفي تبعنا ما بنمرنه
فيه دراسة على الرياضيين
وشافوا أيش التمارين الرياضية اللي بتقلل نسب الإصابة؟
فكان أول تمرين هو الإحماء الحركي ما قبل التمرين
بعدين كانت تمارين المرونة والثبات والتوازن
هذه الأشياء بتقلل من الإصابات
عشان كذا مهم نفحصها ونشوف احنا وين فيها
وبعدين نحسنها عن طريق التمرين
طيب دامنا دخلنا في التمارين
هل الأكثر أهمية للإنسان على المدى البعيد
وعشان يعيش بصحة طيبة إذا كبر في السن
أن يبني كتلة عضلية وللا يكون عنده لياقة عالية؟
كمان شغلتين ما حكينا عنهم اللي هم
اللياقة القلبية العالية والكتلة العضلية العالية، الثنتين مهمين
عشان أنت تعمّر بطريقة صحية
مش لازم تكون عداء خرافي، مش لازم تكون حامل أوزان خرافي
مش شرط تكون عندك مثلًا مرونة عالية مثل لاعب جمباز
لازم تكون متوسط بكل هذه الأشياء
متوسط بالمرونة، متوسط بالكتلة العضلية، متوسط اللياقة القلبية
فكلهم مهمين على نفس القدر
لو باختار واحد منهم أيهما أهم؟
هل أني أبني كتلة عضلية فهي اللي بتساعدني أن ما تجيني ألام أكثر؟
وللا اللياقة القلبية بتقيني من أمراض القلب؟
يمكن لو نصنفهم اللياقة القلبية أعلى
فيه واحدة من قياسات للياقة القلبية شيء اسمه الـ «VO2 Max»
اللي هو القدرة القصوى على استهلاك الأكسجين في العضلات
وبيعكس القدرة القلبية الرئوية تبعنا
والحين بنحكي عن كيف ممكن نقيس أو كيف ممكن نمرنها
هذا القياس بنعمله بالمختبر، الواحد بيركض على جهاز مشي
وبنقيس استهلاكه للأكسجين وبنعرف وين هو
هذا القياس مرتبط بشكل كبير بالتعمير
وتقليل خطر الإصابة بالأمراض المزمنة وخطر الوفاة
الحلو مش بس أن «VO2 Max» المرتفع جيد للصحة
إذا بديت من «VO2 Max» منخفض ورفعته، بيزيد...
الدراسات بتقول: أنه بتقلل نسبة الإصابة بالأمراض المزمنة بشكل كبير
إذا بترفع الـ«VO2 Max» تبعك أعتقد خمس درجات
بتقلل نسبة الوفاة بنسبة 50% تقريبًا
اللي هو شيء كبير مقارنة بالقياسات الأخرى للصحة
فأعتقد اللياقة القلبية هي الأعلى
هو موجود في ساعة أبل، كيف القياس حقها؟
قياس ساعة أبل هو بيعطيك تقدير
ما مداه يعني؟
مش كثير دقيق
ساعة «قارمن» أنا شفت الدقة تبعها أعلى بالنسبة للـ«VO2 Max»
إذا تبغى تقيسه بشكل دقيق جدًّا، لازم هو فحص مخبري
يعني يبغى له أجهزة معينة
بس ساعة أبل جيدة كتقدير
تعطيك تصور يعني؟
ممكن، مع أن شفت فيها مشاكل
أنا قارنت بينها وبين الفحص الدقيق، كان فيه شوية اختلاف
طيب جالس بطلع لأني بشوف أيش المقياس اللي عندي في الجوال
كيف تقدر ترفع من اللياقة القلبية؟
أتذكر أنه كان في المتوسط أو تحت المتوسط، ناسي والله
ما قدرت أجيبه لك بسرعة
بقول لك أني ألعب كرة
أروح النادي ثلاث إلى أربع مرات في الأسبوع
فما أعرف والله، بس يمكن الساعة ماهي دقيقة أبدًا
أفضل طريقة أنك ترفع الـ «VO2 Max»
هي عن طريق رياضة عالية الحدة المتواترة الـ«هيت»
ويمكن أفضل بروتوكول إذا بنعمل بروتوكول دقيق
اللي أنا بتبعه، هو أربعة بأربعة بأربعة
أربعة دقائق من الركض أو أنا بستعمل دراجة
أربع دقائق من الرياضة عالية الحدة
بنسبة خلينا نحكي 90% من القدرة تبعك
وإذا بنكون أدق 90% من عدد نبضات القلب القصوى تبعك
اللي بنعرفه عن طريق 220 ناقص العمر
بعدين 90% منه بنوصل لهذه الدرجة لمدة أربع دقائق
بعدين أربعة دقائق بحدة متوسطة اللي هي 50% - 70%
من عدد نبضات القلب القصوى أو القدرة القصوى تبعك
أربعة أربعة، بعدين بنعيد هذه العملية أربع مرات
فبنكون وصلنا إلى 28 دقيقة أو شيء مثل كذا
وهذا التمرين إذا بتعمله مرة أسبوعيًّا فقط
راح تشوف ارتفاع كبير بالـ«VO2 Max» تبعك
أعتقد شفنا ارتفاع بنسبة خمس درجات على مدى ست أسابيع فقط
من التمرين هذا مرة أسبوعيًّا عند بعض الناس
بيفرق إذا كان دراجة وللا جهاز مشي؟
ما بيفرق، أنا بفضّل الدراجة
لأن بحس التغير ما بين التمرين والثاني أقل
فأنا بستعمل الدراجة
وفكرة أنك تركب دراجة هذه المنطقة الثانية؟
أيوة، المنطقة الثانية هي تقريبًا الحدة المتوسطة
فيفضّل أن يكون معظم الرياضة تبعنا تكون بالمنطقة الثانية
و 20% من الرياضة تبعنا تكون بالحدة العالية
إذا بنعمل مثلًا المنطقة الثانية حدة متوسطة
ثلاث أو أربع مرات أسبوعيًّا
ووحدة منهم نعمل بعدها «هيت» عالية الحدة
يمكن هذا الشيء جيد
طبعًا هذه موجودة في ساعة أبل
برضه يحط لك في أي منطقة أنت موجود فيها
فهذا التمرين بيساعد في اللياقة القلبية
100%
طيب فيه شيء ثاني غير اللياقة القلبية بالنسبة للتمارين؟
حكينا عن أيش؟ الكتلة العضلية
الكتلة العضلية؟
هذا الشيء نرفعه عن طريق تناول البروتين بشكل جيد
ومعظم الناس ما بتتناول البروتين كافي
بيختلف إذا تبغى تخسر وزن أو تبغى تزيد وزن
إذا هدفك خسارة الوزن
بنصح ببروتين 1.8 لكل كيلوقرام من وزن الجسم
إذا تبغى تزيد وزنك وتبغى تبني كتلة عضلية
1.8
إيه؟
1.8 قرام بروتين لكل كيلوقرام من وزن الجسم
فكيف تحسبها؟
أحسب وزن جسمك أضربه 1.8
بيطلع لك وبعدين وزعهم على ثلاثة أو أربعة وجبات يوميًا
كثير، هذا وزنك الحالي وللا وزنك المثالي؟
وزنك الحالي إذا وزنك مرتفع
إذا مؤشر كتلة جسمك أعلى من 25
وبالأخص إذا كان أعلى من 30؛ لا، أستعمل الوزن المثالي
طيب البروتين، هل تأخذه كبودرة أو أشياء ثانية وللا من الأكل الطبيعي؟
ما تفرق كثير صراحة، بس عادي ممكن تاخذه من البودرة
أنا شخصيًّا باخذه من الأكل الطبيعي أكثر شيء
بس ما عندي مشكلة مع المكملات الغذائية البروتينية
طيب الآن بالنسبة للأكل
مشكلة الأكل مشكلة، لأن ما في أحد يتفق على أي شيء
حتى في نفس النطاق اللي الحين بنكلم فيه
أنت وفيه اللي هو «ديفيد سنكلير» بتختلفون كثير
بناءً على اللي عرفته منكم. واثنينكم مهتمين بنفس المجال
وفيه ناس اللي لهم علاقة برضه ...
فالأكل دائمًا مزعج، إذا تبغى تنزل وزن كل واحد يفتيك
ما في أحد قادر على أن يعطينا شكل مثالي للأكل
ودي أسألك على كم نقطة، خلنا نشوف
الصيام المتقطع، كيف تشوفه؟
على أثره الآن على صحتك للمدى البعيد؟
ما فيه شيء يتعلق بالصيام المتقطع بحد ذاته مفيد للصحة
هو إذا اُستخدم كأداة لتقليل السعرات الحرارية ممكن يكون مفيد
وهذه الدراسات عُملت
نقارن بين الناس اللي عملوا صيام متقطع
والناس اللي ما بتعمل صيام متقطع
إذا كانت السعرات الحرارية متشابهة
النتائج النهائية بتكون متشابهة
بس فيه ناس يقول لك: كلما زاد جسمك بشعور بالجوع
كلما كانت الخلايا تختلف طريقتها في التعامل معه
فيفيدك على المدى البعيد
فالشعور بالجوع هو الشيء اللي أنت تبحث عنه
أكثر من السعرات الحرارية وكميتها
فيه ناس بتحكي بطريقة ميكانيكية
أيوة فيه عندنا مثلًا دراسات بتقول
أن لما الخلايا تدخل بحالة من الجوع بتزيد حالة الترميم
بس في الدراسات السريرية على الإنسان
ما بنشوف هذا الشيء له نتائج إيجابية بالإنسان بشكل عام
هذه المواضيع ممكن مخبريًّا تكون حقيقية
بس لما بنعمل الدراسات السريرية، ما بنشوف نتائج نهائية مختلفة
فلما نأخذ الحين السعرات الحرارية
كيف الواحد يقيس السعرات الحرارية المناسبة لجسمه؟
فيه معادلات يقدر يستخدمها الواحد
وبتختلف حسب الواحد أيش هدفه النهائي
هل يبغى يقلل السعرات الحرارية أو يبغى يرفعها؟
فيه طرق أكثر دقة بس هي بتحتاج مختبرات
فعادةً الواحد بس بيستعمل المعادلات المعينة
اللي بتعطي بالنسبة لعمرك وبالنسبة لوزنك
قد أيش أنت السعرات الحرارية اللي بتحتاجها
أيش هي هذه المعادلات البسيطة؟
مش حافظها، دوّر عليها عبر الإنترنت وبتلاقيها
طيب، الحين أنا عرفت مثلًا أني افترض 2600 سعرة حرارية
فأني أحافظ على الحد الأدنى أو الحد المثالي
هو الشيء اللي أنت تبغاني أوصل له؟
فأنا أوصل لهذا الحد المثالي للسعرات الحرارية اليومية
وللا الأفضل لصحتي أني أقلل شوية عنها؟
بشكل عام بنصح أن تقلل شوية
لأن عادةً احنا بنعمل تقدير أعلى للسعرات الحرارية اللي بناخذها
فحاول تستهدف أقل بشوية من اللي تحتاجه
وثاني شيء، معظم الناس يحتاجوا يخسروا شوية وزن
بس إذا تبغى تزيد وزنك؛ لا، لازم ترفعه على حسب الشخص
وعلى حسب التمارين وعلى حسب...
إذا بتشوف توزيع السعرات الحرارية اللي بنستهلكها خلال اليوم
وين نستهلك سعراتنا الحرارية؟
معظمها بيروح على معدل حرق السعرات الحرارية وقت الراحة
هذا الشيء بيكون موجود خلال النوم، خلال الاستيقاظ
دائمًا جسمك شغال بيحرق سعرات حرارية
بعدين السعرات الحرارية اللي بنستهلكها خلال الرياضة
بس في جزء ممتع هو اسمه «نيت» (إن إي إيه تي)
«النشاط غير الرياضي»
وهو السعرات الحرارية اللي بنحرقها خلال الحركة، بس مش الحركة الرياضية
وفي كثير من الأحيان بتكون حركة لا واعية
اللي هي مثلًا كيف الناس بتكون تحرك رجله مثلًا، بيحرك يديه
وهذه الشغلة بتختلف بين الناس
وبتختلف حسب الحالات اللي أنت فيها
ففيه ناس جينيًّا عندهم الـ «نيت» مرتفع
تحس أنه يتحرك كثير
عادةً هذول الأشخاص يكون وزنهم منخفض ونحيفين
وبتشوف هذا الشغلة، فيه ناس اللي خلاص جينيًّا نحيفين
حركتهم كثيرة، لأن الـ«نيت» عندهم بيكون مرتفع
وبعدين فيه كمان نصرف سعرات حرارية لحرق الأكل
ففيه أنواع معينة من الأكل
بتحتاج سعرات حرارية أكثر لحرقها مثل البروتين
بس كنسبة هي نسبة صغيرة من السعرات الحرارية الإجمالية
لما يكون وزننا مرتفع واحنا في حالة من الوفرة في الطاقة
الـ«نيت» تبعنا هو لحاله بيزيد، بنصير نتحرك أكثر بشكل لاواعي
ولما نكون في حالة من قلة الطاقة
بنستهلك سعرات حرارية أقل، الـ«نيت» تبعنا بيقل
هذه الأماكن اللي احنا نوزع فيها السعررات الحرارية تبعنا
ونقدر نصرفها ونزيد الصرف في الأماكن هذه
المكان الوحيد اللي نقدر نزيد الصرف فيه هو الرياضة
هل ممكن يجي ضرر من زيادة البروتين؟
لا، ما في ضرر من زيادة البروتين
الدراسات تقول حتى الناس اللي عندهم مشاكل في الكلى
رفع البروتين يزيد الحمل على الكلى
بس ما بيؤدي إلى تدهور في وظائف الكلى
عادة بننصح للناس اللي عنده مشاكل في الكلى
ممكن يقلل من البروتين
بس للناس الطبيعيين؛ ما في ضرر في زيادة البروتين
بس فيه ضرر من زيادة النشويات
حسب إذا بتزيد السعرات الحرارية الإجمالية اللي داخلة من النشويات
بس لأن النشويات والدهون فيها سعرات حرارية عالية
فهذه من الأشياء اللي نبغى نقللها
فيه لك تغريدة كنت تقول: أنك غيّرت رأيك في أهمية الفطور
مثل ما حكيت، أول شيء الكمية بعدين النوعية
توقيت الأكل برضه بيأثر شوي
الدراسات بتقول: أن تناول معظم السعرات الحرارية تبعنا
في الجزء الأول من اليوم، خلال النهار
أفضل من أن نتناول معظمها في الليل
وهذا الشيء مرتبط أول شيء بأنه ممكن يأثر على جودة النوم
لما نتناول معظم السعرات الحرارية تبعنا بالليل
وثاني شيء مرتبط بتغير شوي بعمليات الأيض تبعنا
فبتزيد علامات مقاومة الإنسولين
واضطراب تنظيم سكر الدم بيزيد شوي
بس إجمالًا هي مش شيء كثير مهم بقدر السعرات والنوعية
طيب لما آكل فقط لما أجوع، وللا أني آكل بانتظام
في أوقات محددة، بيفرق وللا ما يفرق؟
ما أعتقد بيفرق
وفيه ناس بيضبط معهم شغلة الصيام المتقطع وأنه يأجل تناول الطعام
والموضوع ديناميكي
أنا مثلًا إذا عارف أن عندي عشاء اليوم
وعارف راح يكون عشاء كبير
ممكن خلاص بأجل
يعني بيقدر الواحد يغيّر بين يوم ويوم
طيب فيه علاقة بين السكر والسكريات
والعمر البيولوجي وللا ما في علاقة؟
إذا قصدك عن تناول السكر مع صحتنا والعلامات الحيوية تبعنا؛ ممكن
بس الأمر متعلق أكتر بالسعرات الحرارية مش بس السكر بحد ذاته
مو في السكر بذاته، هو في السعرات الحرارية
فأنت إذا حليت السعرات الحرارية معظم مشاكلك بتنتهي؟
أيوة، بس المشكلة أن السكر بحد ذاته
فيه كثافة عالية من السعرات الحرارية
فصعب الواحد يتناول كثير سكر بدون ما يزيد السعرات الحرارية
مضادات الأكسدة، مهمة للجسم وللا؟
كنا نعتقد كذا زمان، كان هناك نظرية بتحكي
أن سبب التعمير وسبب التقدم في العمر
هو أن تتراكم مركبات معينة داخل الخلية
بتؤدي إلى اضطراب التفاعلات الكيميائية داخل الخلية
وهذا الشيء يتراكم مع العمر
فكانت النظرية أن إذا بتناول مضادات الأكسدة
اللي بتقلل من هذه المركبات في الخلية
هذا الشيء مفيد للتقدم في العمر
بس كانت نظرية فاشلة تطبيقيًّا
لأن مضادات الأكسدة طلعت ما بتأثر كثير
وطلع يمكن الأصح هو لازم يكون عندنا
شوية أكسدة ولازم يكون عندنا شوية مضادات أكسادة
فهي شغلة توازن
وعشان نفهم موضوع الأكسدة أكثر
احنا ليه بنتنفس؟ كل خلايانا بتحتاج أكسجين
ليه بنحتاج هذا الأكسجين؟
لما نتنفس بيدخل الأكسجين للجسم
بيدخل إلى الخلايا، بيوصل إلى الخلايا
بعدين فيه أعضاء أو عضويات داخل الخلية، تسمى «الميتوكندريا»
تستعمل الأكسجين لتحوّل الجلوكوز إلى طاقة
فبينتج عن هذه العملية هذه المركبات
وعادةً الخلية بتقدر تتخلص منها بشكل سريع
بس مع التقدم في العمر بتقل قدرة الخلية على التخلص منها
فهنا جات فكرة مضادات الأكسدة
بس مثل ما حكيت، تطبيقيًّا ما كان لها تأثير كثير
أيش أكثر الأشياء طيب اللي لها تأثير والناس مهملتها؟
من الناحية التغذوية
أنا دائمًا بحكي أنه فيه مثل الطبقات للموضوع
أول شيء هي الأشياء الحياتية اللي حكينا عنها
الرياضة والنوم والتغذية وتقليل السعرات الحرارية
والصحة النفسية والابتعاد عن الأشياء اللي بتضرنا مثل التدخين والكحول
هذه الأساسيات كلها مهمة
ما في وحدة مهمة عن الثانية
بعدين نجي نشوف مسببات الوفاة الرئيسية
والأمراض المتعلقة بالتقدم في العمر الأساسية
ونشوف كيف نقدر نتجنبها وحدة وحدة
طيب فيه المكملات الغذائية قبل نوصل للأمراض وندخل فيها
المكملات الغذائية حولها نقاش كثير
فيها ناس تشوفها مهمة وفيه ناس تشوفها غير مهمة
وفيه حديث حولها كثير
فيه ناس تنظر لها أنه إذا أنت قدرت تحصل على هذه الأشياء
من أكلك الطبيعي فهو أفضل
وفيه ناس تشوف أن بغض النظر عن طبيعة أكلك
مفترض أنك تاخذ مكملات غذائية، حكيني
أي شيء بنعمله؛ أنا بشوفه من ناحيتين
ناحية الفائدة المرجوة وناحية التكلفة
فمثلًا الرياضة الفائدة المرجوة تبعها عالية
والتكلفة تبعها بصنفها عالية
لأنه تستهلك وقت كثير، تصرف خمس ساعات أسبوعيًّا
هذه تكلفة وقتية عالية
فالتكلفة ممكن تكون مادية وممكن تكون وقت
بس لأن فائدتها عالية؛ تستاهل أن نصرف عليها
المكملات الغذائية معظمها بصنفها فائدة مرجوة قليلة
وممكن تكلفة عالية أحيانًا، صح وللا لا؟
فعشان كذا مش ضرورية جدًّا
بس ممكن تكون فيه مكملات غذائية عليها أدلة أنها مفيدة شوي
وحدة من الأشياء اللي بنصح فيها لمعظم الناس هي «الكيرياتين»
وحدة من الأشياء اللي بتدعم الكتلة العضلية ولها جوانب إيجابية
وعليها أبحاث كثير بتقول أنها آمنة
عادةً بنصح من ثلاث إلى خمسة قرام يوميًأ
فيتامين دال، معظمنا عندنا نقص بالفيتامين دال
يفضّل الواحد يفحص أول قبل ما يأخذ فيتامين دال
عشان يعرف الجرعة المناسب له
ويعرف إذا بيحتاج ياخذ فيتامين دال
هذه واحدة من الأشياء اللي عليها أدلة
الـ«أستيل الكارنتين» مكمل غذائي مرتبط بعلامات صحية أفضل أحيانًا
بس مثل ما حكيت فائدة لا تذكر مقابل أشياء مثل الرياضة
والمحافظة على وزن جيد والأشياء اللي حكينا عنها قبل
فيه مكملات أخرى ثانية عندي ببعث لك إياها
دليل للمكملات الغذائية على الموقع حقي
ممتاز، خلاص بنحطها في النشرة لهذه الحلقة
مثلًا هنا «بيتر عطية» يقول: أنها مهمة جدًّا
أيش هي؟
المكملات الغذائية
وكمان «ديفيد سنكلير»
فهل هي بهذه الأهمية مرة؟
وأنت الحين خففت أهميتها صراحة
أيوة، لأنه حسب المكمل الغذائي وحسب لأيش بتستعمله
أنا بصنفها أن بعض المكملات الغذائية مفيدة
لكن مش أول شيء بشوفه، يعني بعد الرياضة والتغذية الجيدة
ممكن الواحد يدعم بمكملات غذائية
فيه مكملات غذائية أخرى ما تكلمنا عنها مثل مساحيق البروتين
هذه تعتبر مكمل غذائي
إذا أنت ما بتتناول بروتين بكمية عالية
فهنا البروتين ممكن يصنف
مكمل غذائي مهم
ما تقدر صدق أنك توصل للكمية حق البروتين اللي تحتاجها كل يوم
فأحس رغم أنه مهم، بس عاد صعب
سبحان الله، الأشياء السهلة هي السكريات
طيب، هل هذه المكملات الغذائية اللي يقولك: هذا يقوّي الذاكرة
هل هو دقيق وللا تجاري؟
معظمه تجاري، وفيه كثير كلام عن مكملات غذائية
أنت حكيت عن «ديفيد سنكلير» مثلًا
الناس اللي تتابع «ديفيد سنكلير» بيحكوا كثير عن أشياء
مثل «روزفيلترول» و «إن إم إن»
بصراحة الأدلة عليها ضعيفة جدًّا أن لها أي أهمية
أنا ما بنصح فيهم
وعادةً المكملات الغذائية لو لها تأثير قوي جدًّا
بتصير تصنف كأدوية
فيه كثير أدوية مفيدة جدًّا
فيه مثلًا مكملات غذائية مفيدة لإرتفاع ضغط الدم
الناس اللي عندهم ارتفاع ضغط الدم
بيقدروا يستفيدوا من أشياء مثل الكركدية ، مستخلص ورق الزيتون، الثوم
هذه الأشياء بتساعد، وفيه أدلة جيدة
على أنها ممكن تساعد شوي
طيب، وهناك مكملة غذائية خاصة بالنوم، كيف تراها؟
خصوصًا النوم مهم جدًّا لطول عمر الإنسان
أو حتى تكون العضلات أو لأي شيء يحتاجه الإنسان
أيوة وهذه شغلة مهمة
لأن فيه أدوية ومكملات غذائية بتساعد على النوم
بس ممكن تكون مش كثير مفيدة للنوم
معظم الأدوية المنومة اللي الناس بياخذوها
بتقلل من جودة النوم مع أنها ممكن تساعد
في أن الواحد يدخل ويستمر في النوم
وفيه مكملات غذائية مفيدة أهمها هو «الماقنيسيوم»
«الماقنيسيوم» بشكلين عليها أكثر أدلة
اللي هي «الماقنيسيوم قلوكينيت» و«الماقنيسيوم ثرينيت»
هذول الشكلين اللي أنا بنصح فيهم، 200 ميلي قرام كحد أدنى
طيب ليش الواحد إذا كبر في السن تقل جودة نومه؟
أو يقل حتى ساعات نومه؟
فيه نظريتين للموضوع: أن احنا نحتاج نوم أقل مع التقدم في السن
أو ممكن احنا بننام أقل، وهذا الشيء بيساهم في تقدمنا بالسن
مش معروف تقريبًا
بس لما نشوف البيئة الداخلية للجسم مع التقدم في العمر
البيئة الداخلية في الجسم بتصير تشبه حالة الـ«جت لاق» بس طبيعيًّا
فكيف لما تسافر على مكان بعيد ويتخربط النوم تبعك، ليش؟
لأنه بتصير فيه خربطة بالهرمونات
تبع الدورة اليوماوية أو الدورة الحيوية تبعك
بس هذا الشيء بصير لحاله مع التقدم في العمر
فعلى الأغلب هذا بيقلل من جودة النوم تبعنا مع التقدم في العمر
أنت كم ساعة تنام في اليوم؟
أحاول أستهدف سبعة إلى ثمان ساعات
بس مش المدة مهمة
فيه ثلاث أنواع أنا بصنفهم من المشاكل في النوم
عدم الدخول في النوم بسرعة
عدم الحصول على وقت كافي من النوم
وعدم الاستمرار في النوم وجودة النوم نفسها
فلكل واحدة منهم فيه تدخلات ممكن تساعد
من التدخلات اللي بتساعد في كلهم تقريبًا
أن نحافظ على موعد نوم وموعد استيقاظ ثابت
حتى في أيام نهاية الأسبوع
وعادةً يفرق الليل عن النهار؟
نعم بيفرق طبعًا، النوم بالليل كثير مفيد أكثر من النوم في النهار
حتى لدرجة أن منظمة الصحة العالمية
فيها تصنيفات لمواد وتصرفات ممكن تزيد خطر الإصابة بالسرطان
ففيه ثلاث تصنيفات
التصنيف الأول، أشياء مرتبطة بشكل مباشر بالسرطان
التصنيف الثاني، أشياء ممكن تزيد نسبة السرطان
والتصنيف الثالث، أشياء بدرجة أقل ممكن تزيد نسبة الإصابة بالسرطان
العمل الليلي، هي بالتصنيف الثاني
تخيل مرتبط بزيادة بالسرطان
لهذه الدرجة مهم أن الواحد ينام بالليل ويستيقظ في النهار
حتى لو نمت في الغرفة مظلمة تمامًا وللا ما يفرق؟
هي المشكلة أن لازم تعود جسمك على فترة طويلة
أن يعيد تنظيم الساعة البيولوجي تبعه، بس التقلب سيء جدًّا
كان الله في عون الناس اللي تدوام دوام ليلي
متى دوامك؟ هل هو ثابت في موعد محدد؟
أيوة، بصحى في موعد محدد
بس دوامك متى؟
أنا ما عندي دوام محدد، حسب أحيانًا بيكون عندي عيادة بوقت محدد
بس عادةً 9:00 صباحًا بكون بدأت شغل
لأنه أيش اللي يصير؟
الحمد لله عادةً ما يكون عندي شيء في الصباح
وأحاول أنام بدري، أنام على 11:00 تقريبًا، فأصحى بكير
بس إذا نمت متأخر برضه، ما عندي مشكلة أصحى متأخر
وما عندي مشكلة مع الدوام
فما أحط منبه
فأنا أنام وأصحى، إذا صحيت أقوم ما في شيء
هو رائع، بس ما شعرت بروعته إلا كان يوم
حطيت منبه، ما أدري والله أيش كان عندي
بس اضطريت أني أشغّل المنبه
ويوم صحيت مع المنبه، أنزعجت
يومي كان سيء أول ثلاثة أو أربع ساعات
على فكرة، الاستيقاظ بالمنبه لحاله، يزيد من...
فيه دراسات على هذا الموضوع
قارنوا بين الناس اللي بتستيقظ بدون منبه ومع منبه
الناس اللي بتستيقظ مع منبه بيزيد عندهم عدد نبضات القلب
بيزيد ضغط الدم تبعهم خلال الفترة الصباحية
واللي بدون منبه يصير حياتهم حلوة
بالضبط
كيف تقدر ترتب يومك أنك...؟
أنا بحكي عن المنبهات التقليدية الصوتية
بس احتمال يكون فيه طريقة بين الثنين
اللي هي استخدام المنبهات الضوئية أو المنبهات الحرارية
فهذا يكون ضوء كبير، على مدى نصف ساعة من قبل الاستيقاظ
بيصير أعلى وأعلى وبعدين بالآخر انت راح تستيقظ
فيمكن هذه طريقة طبيعية أكثر للاستيقاظ
مثلًا أنا إذا سافرت، مثلًا في الفندق أحب أخلي الستارة مفتوحة
ليه؟
عشان الشمس اللي تصحيني
بس راح تصحى بكير وللا لا؟
أبغى أصحى بكير
إذا بتحب
إيه، لأنك لو سكّرت صدق ممكن تطول نومتك
أو بتحتاج إلى منبهة عشان تصحى الصباح
بس يمكن أنت بتحتاج نوم أطول
فأقول لك أني أنام بدري، أنا نام لثمان أو سبع ساعات
هو أفضل شيء أن الواحد ينام بدري ويصحى على الفجر
هذه الحالة المثالية خلينا نقول
بس هذا مثلًا مطب أسويها حتى أصحى بدون منبه
فأيش يجي ببالك شغلات؟
فيه شغلة، لما يدرسوا المجتمعات الإنسانية
اللي بيسموها ما قبل التطور الحديث
الناس اللي بيعيشوا بدون كهرباء وبدون الأشياء الحديثة
بيشوفوا أن الإنسان بينام مش لما تنزل الشمس
الإنسان بينام لما تنزل درجة الحرارة
فهذه من الأشياء اللي ما بنحكي عنها كثير
هي فعليًّا أن التطور الحديث
أثّر بشكل سلبي على النوم بشكل عام
بسبب الإنارة الداخلية، يمكن بشكل أكبر بسبب التدفئة المنزلية
احنا المحيط تبعنا ما تنزل درجة حرارته بشكل طبيعي
فعشان كذا هذا الشيء بيأثر على جودة النوم تبعنا
مهتم بالنوم جدًّا ففيه حلقتين سويتها مع دكتورين مختصين بالنوم
برضه بتكون في النشرة
فهي رائعة وأهمية النوم
دائمًا أحس أن كثرة النوم تعتبر شيء سلبي بالنسبة للناس
بس أثرها على صحة الإنسان مش طبيعية
100%
فأحس أن الناس تقدر تهتم
لهذا ودي انتقل إلى الأمراض
الحين عندنا الأمراض القاتلة، أنت قلت بالترتيب
أمراض القلب والشرايين
أمراض القلب والشرايين، السرطان، الأمراض العصبية والأمراض الأيضية
الأمراض الأيضية ممكن تسبب الوفاة
بس عادةً هي بتزيد من نسبة إصابة الأمراض الأخرى اللي حكينا عنها
أمراض القلب والعصبية والسرطان كمان
وبرضه بعدين ممكن فيه الأمراض الرئوية المزمنة
وأمراض الفشل الكلوي كمان بتصير مع التقدم في العمر
فهذه هي الأمراض اللي تصيبنا مع التقدم في العمر
اللي في النهاية تؤدي إلى وفاتنا
وعادةً هذه جينية وللا نمط حياة أثرها؟
هي راح تصيب الكل في الآخر
فهي مبرمجة فينا جينيًّا أن تصيبنا هذه الأمراض مع التقدم في العمر
ولكن فيه عامل حياتي ممكن يسرّع إصابتنا بهذه الأمراض
من وين تجي أمراض القلب والشرايين؟
أمراض القلب والشرايين بما أنها الأكثر وفاة
هو واحد من كل ثلاثة يموتون من أمراض القلب والشرايين؟
احنا عن أيش بنحكي عن أمراض القلب والشرايين؟
عادةً نحكي عن شيء اسمه تصلب الشرايين
واللي هي تغيرات بتصير في جدران الشرايين اللي بتغذي القلب
وكمان الشرايين اللي بتغذي الدماغ وكل شرايين جسمنا
بتصير هذه التغييرات بتبدأ من عمر بكير، من العشرينات والثلاثينات
وبتتراكم مع العمر
اللي بصير أن الخلايا المبطنة للشرايين بيصير فيها تلف
وبتدخل بعض أنواع المركبات منها الكوليسترول مثلًا
بيدخل في جدران الأوعية الدموية هذه
وبيصير فيه تفاعلات كيميائية معينة
بتؤدي إلى تصلب هذه الشرايين
وبتؤدي إلى نقص التروية اللي تجي من هذه الشرايين إلى القلب
وبالنهاية ممكن تنكسر هذه المناطق وتؤدي إلى الإنسداد
وتؤدي إلى الجلطات القلبية والدماغية
هذه العملية البطيئة جدًّا بتصير على مدى عقود
وتبدأ في عمر مبكر
فهذا المرض الأساسي اللي بنحكي عنه
لما نحكي عن أمراض القلب والشرايين
اللي بنحاول نمنع تراكمه مع التقدم في العمر
وين أروح عشان أكشف؟
هل هو المستشفيات وللا العيادات المتخصصة وللا؟
لا فيه أشياء ممكن نعملها عن طريق فحوصات الدم
ممكن تساعدنا نعرف وين احنا بهذه المرحلة
بس خلينا ناخد خطوة لوراء
أول شيء لازم نشوفه هو التاريخ العائلي تبعنا
إذا فيه أمراض قلب في العائلة
وخاصة عند الناس القريبين لأهلنا وأخواننا
وخاصة إذا كانت إصابتهم بهذه الأمراض بعمر صغير
تحت الخمسة وخمسين أو تحت الستين
هذا الشيء بيزيد من نسبة إصابتنا بهذه الأمراض
ثاني شيء نشوف حياتنا الشخصية
معليش السبب الأول اللي هو تاريخ العائلة
العائلة المباشرة الحين اللي هو أخوانك وأبوك وأمك
وللا تبغى برضه جدي؟
هل أنا أقيسه أو أعرفه بالملاحظة؟
وللا أروح أسوي اختبارات جينية وغيره؟
فيه اختبارات جينية ممكن تعملها
فيه تغيرات جينية معينة بتزيد نسبة الإصابة بالأمراض
بس ما تقدر تعرف كل التغييرات الجينية اللي عندك إياها
التاريخ العائلي هو إشارة أقوى أن عندك ارتفاع بالنسبة للإصابة
بناءً على هل جدي صار له، هل أبوي صار له؟
إذا ما صار، معناته ما فيه
إذا فيه أي تاريخ مرضي بالعائلة لأمراض القلب
هذا الشيء بيزيد نسبة إصابتك تقريبًا
بالآخر الكل راح يكون عنده نوع من أنواع أمراض القلب
مع التقدم في العمر
فإذا مثلًا جدك كان عمره 95 سنة وأصيبه بأمراض القلب
هذا شيء طبيعي خلينا نحكيها
بس كل ما قل عمر الإصابة كل ما زادت النسبة
إذا كان خارج الطبيعي؟ الطبيعي كل ما كبر السن، واضح
فهذا تاريخ العائلة، الشيء ثاني؟
التاريخ الشخصي لك
فأول شيء الناس اللي أصابهم أمراض قلب من قبل
هذا الشيء بيزيد نسبة إصابتهم في المستقبل
فيه جمعية القلب الأمريكية حطوا ثمان عوامل
بتزيد من نسبة إصابة الشخص بأمراض القلب والشرايين
أول وحدة ارتفاع ضغط الدم، ارتفاع سكر الدم
ارتفاع كوليسترول الدم، الكوليسترول المسبب لتصلب الشرايين
الوزن الزائد وبالأخص الدهون الوسطية
الخمول وعدم ممارسة الرياضة
النوم الغير الجيد، كان وحدة من الأشياء اللي حكوا عنها
أيش باقي؟ يمكن التغذية الغير جيدة والأشياء المصنعة والمكررة
أعتقد أنها كانت واحدة من الأشياء، والتدخين
كل هذه الأشياء عوامل ممكن تغييرها
بتزيد من نسبة الإصابة بأمراض القلب والشرايين
فنبغى نقيس كل هذه الأشياء، أول شيء بنبدأ بالعوامل الشخصية
اللي هي: هل أنا مدخن أم لا؟ هل وزني زائد أم لا؟
هل عندي دهون وسطية؟ دهون حشوية؟
هذه الأشياء اللي حكينا عنها قبل
بعدين فيه فحوصات دم ممكن نعملها
اللي هي الكوليسترول ودهون الدم
هنا نشوف أشياء مثل الدهون الثلاثية
نشوف أشياء
مثل ما يسمى «صميم البروتين الشحمي - ب» (Apolipoprotein B)
وحدة من الفحوصات اللي نشوفها
نشوف فحص اسمه «إل دي إل كوليسترول»
والـ « إتش دي إل كوليسترول»
هي أنواع مختلفة من...
خلينا نحكي شوي عن الكوليسترول عشان نفهم عن أيش بنحكي
الكوليسترول كثير من الناس بيفهموه خطأ
الكوليسترول مش شيء سيء للجسم بشكل عام أو بالمطلق
كل خلايا أجسامنا تحتاج كوليسترول للقيام بوظائفها الحيوية
ومعظم خلايا أجسامنا عندها القدرة أنها تصنع الكوليسترول بذاتها
وأجسامنا بتصنع الكوليسترول
معظم الكوليسترول في دمنا بينصنع من الجسم تبعنا
والكبد بيصنع كوليسترول زائد وبيضخه في الدم
والخلايا اللي بتحتاج كوليسترول بتاخذ من الدم
فالكوليسترول بالمطلق مش شيء ضار
ولكن ارتفاع الكوليسترول في الدم
بيصير يدخل في الشرايين وجدران الشرايين
وهذا الشيء مع التقدم في العمر
مرتبط بزيادة تصلب الشرايين وأمراض القلب
كيف ينتقل الكوليسترول في الدم؟
مثل ما بنعرف الدهون ما بتذوب في الماء
فبيحتاج نواقل معينة
فيتم تغليف دهون الدم بالأشياء نسميها الـ«لايبو بروتينز»
اللي هي بنقيسها لما نعمل فحوصات الدم
فنشوف إذا الـ«لايبو بروتينز» مرتفعة
هذا الشيء يعطيبنا فكرة أن الدهون في الدم مرتفعة
وهذا الشيء مرتبط بزيادة تصلب الشرايين
بس الشغلة اللي كثير من الناس ما بيفهموها
هو أن درجة الارتفاع مش بس هي المهمة
مدة التعرض لهذا الارتفاع بنفس قدر الأهمية
فإذا عندنا ارتفاع طفيف في الـ«إل دي إل كوليسترول»
أو الـ «صميم البروتين الشحمي - ب» (Apolipoprotein B) بهذه الفحوصات
من عمر صغير، ارتفاع طفيف بس هذا الارتفاع
استمر لعشر وعشرين وثلاثين سنة
هذا الشيء راح يزيد من نسبة التعرض لتصلب الشرايين
هذا الشيء اللي أنا ما بحبه في الطب الكلاسيكي والطب الحديث
أنه ما يُعنى كثير بهذه النظرة بعيدة المدى
عادةً إذا بتروح على الدكتور وبيشوف أنك شخص في بداية الثلاثينات
وعندك ارتفاع طفيف في الكوليسترول
بيحكي لك: ارجع لي لما يكون عمرك ستين سنة
وعندك نفس درجة الكوليسترول
بيعطيك وقتها خافض للكوليسترول
بس احنا بنعرّض الخلايا والشرايين تبعنا
لهذا الارتفاع حتى لو كان طفيف لفترة طويلة
هذا الشيء راح يزيد من التعرض للتصلب في الشرايين
الشكل المثالي أنك تاخذ خافض كوليسترول
أول ما يكون عندك ارتفاع بسيط؟
أنا بشجع على هذا الشيء نعم، وفيه دراسة جديدة
نشرت أعتقد بمجلة «جاما» بتقول أن الخفض الشديد للكوليسترول
ما له آثار جانبية سيئة على الصحة
بالعكس له آثار جيدة لأنه بيخفض الكوليسترول على المدى البعيد
وهذا الشيء بيقلل من الإصابة بتصلب الشرايين
أنا شخصيًّا باخذ خافض للكوليسترول
مع أن عندي ارتفاع طفيف
بس لأن ما أبغى أتعرّض للارتفاع الطفيف هذا لمدة ثلاثين سنة قادمة
والجسم ما يتعامل معها تلقائيًّا ويبدأ يخفضها وللا؟
معظم الارتفاع بالكوليسترول هو ارتفاع جيني
يمكن 20% من الكوليسترول في الدم هو من الأكل اللي بناكله
بس 80% منه هو يصنع في الجسم
الزيادة هذه سببها جيني
فحتى لو ضبطنا أكلنا وحسننا أكلنا
الانخفاض ما راح يكون كبير عند معظم الناس
فيحتاج تدخل دوائي
فهذا الكوليسرول
حكينا ضغط الدم وارتفاع سكر الدم، ممكن نحكي عنهم كل واحد
ارتفاع ضغط الدم كمان شيء مهم
لأنه برضه هذا من الأشياء اللي بتكون مرتفعة بدون ما نعرف
ارتفاع ضغط الدم يسمونه القاتل الصامت
لأنه ممكن يكون ضغط دمك مرتفع جدًّا
وأنت مش حاسس، ما له أعراض
فما بتقدر تعرف غير لما تقيس ضغط الدم
هو مش فحص دم هو جهاز، كلنا يمكن نعرفه
ارتفاع ضغط الدم برضه مشابه لارتفاع الكوليسترول
والجهاز اللي تضغط عليه، يضغط على يدك؟
عادة الجهاز الإلكتروني هو لحاله بيضغط على يدك وبيقيس
أيش الفكرة؟ أيش اللي يحصل لما ...
هو أيش بيعمل؟
الشرايين تبعك بيسدها، بعدين بيبدأ يفك شوي شوي
بيقيس أعلى ضغط وأخفض ضغط
القلب ينقبض بعدين بينبسط
فبيقيس الضغط خلال الإنقباض وخلال الإنبساط
وعشان كذا ناخذ رقمين، الرقم العالي والرقم المنخفض
كلاهما مهمين
بس الفكرة بشكل عام في ضغط الدم
نفس الشيء، الارتفاع الطفيف بضغط الدم على فترة طويلة
بيزيد من نسبة إصابتنا بهذه الأمراض
فعشان كذا لما نعرف أن عندنا ارتفاع بضغط الدم مبكرًا مهم
الحين أيش ضغط الدم المثالي؟
عادةً نحكي 120 / 80 لمعظم الناس
يختلف حسب الشخص إذا كان عنده سكري أو مشاكل في الضغط
نستهدف ضغوطات مختلفة، لكن بشكل عام كذا
في الدراسات لما نشوف عدد كبير من الناس
بنشوف أن كلما قل ضغط حتى عن 120 / 80
كلما قلّت نسبة الإصابة بأمراض القلب الشرايين والوفاة
فيمكن الضغط المثالي أقل كمان حتى من 120 / 80
بس مش معناه أن إذا ضغطك مثلًا 120 / 80
لازم تاخذ أدوية بتقلل الضغط
ممكن تعمل ممارسات بتقلل الضغط
وفيه شغلة حلوة
فيه أنواع من الرياضة مخصصة بتأثر على ضغط الدم
بشكل أكبر من أنواع أخرى من الرياضة
هذه الشغلة تعلمتها جديد، وفيه دراسة كثير حلوة
شافوا كل أنواع الرياضة: المقاومة اللياقة القلبية ورياضات المرونة
وكانت النتيجة مفاجأة شوي
أن نوع الرياضة اللي بيؤثر على ضغط الدم بشكل أكبر
هي التمارين «الآيزومترية»
أيش هي التمارين «الآيزومترية»؟
هي التمارين اللي بتقبض فيها العضلة
وبتحافظ على هذا الانقباض لفترة طويلة لبعض الدقائق
معظم الناس ما بيمارسوا هذا النوع من التمرين
بعطيك مثال عليه، أنك تعمل قرفصاء على الحاط بدرجة 90
الحوض يكون 90 درجة
تكون بهذه الوضعية لمدة دقيقتين، بعدين تريّح دقيقة
بعدين تعيد هذه العملية أربع أو خمس مرات
الدراسات بتقول لنا: أن هذا التمرين اعمله خمس مرات أسبوعيًّا
لمدة ستة أسابيع
مرتبط بتقليل ضغط الدم بنسبة عشر درجات عشرة مليمتر زئبقي
طيب «البلانك» نفس الشيء؟
«البلانك» واحد منهم، فيه ممكن تعمله تتمارين باليد
أي شيء يخليك ثابت
حتى باليد، يعني أنك تقبض على كرة مطاطية
نفس الشيء لمدة دقيقتين وتريّح، وتعيد هذه العملية
وهذا الانخفاض برضه بيشوفوه في الناس
اللي معدل ضغط الدم عندهم طبيعي
أنا صرت أحاول أضيف هذه التمارين على...
بس انخفاض ضغط الدم هل ممكن يكون سلبي؟
أيوة، إذا بيؤدي لعوارض سلبية؛ ممكن يكون سلبي
إذا عندك ضغط دم منخفض بس ما عندك أعراض سلبية
مثل الدوخة أو نقص التروية للدماغ؛ عادي شيء طبيعي
فهذا ضغط الدم، عندنا دهون الدم؟
حكينا عن دهون الدم صح؟
دهون الدم حكينا ليش هي مهمة
بس ما حكينا عن التدخلات الطبية اللي بتخفضها
لأن هنا فيه شغلة مهمة وبرضه فيه شوي جدل
حول الكوليسترول ودهون الدم
فيه ناس يعتقدوا أن الكوليسترول مش مهم كثير
وفيه ناس يعتقدوا أن ارتفاع الكوليسترول في الدم شيء جيد
وللأسف فيه ناس يروجوا لهذا الشيء
ما بعرف ليه هو صار موضوع جدلي في عالمنا هذا
في عالم وسائل التواصل
بس معظم أطباء القلب يتفقوا أن هو شيء سلبي
واحنا هنا بنحكي عن الكوليسترول المسبب لتصلب الشرايين
مش بس أي نوع من الكوليسترول
ليه هذا الشيء موجود؟
لأن لما نشوف دراسات مقطعية
لما نقارن بين كوليسترول الدم مع خطر الوفاة
بنشوف أن كل ما انخفض الكوليسترول بتزيد نسبة الوفاة
فهذا شيء عكس اللي كنا نحكيه قبل، صح؟
بس فعليًّا هذه الدراسات مبنية على المشاهدة
فالعلاقة عكسية أحيانًا بتكون في هذه الدراسات
أيش قصدي هنا؟
لما نشوف الناس اللي عندهم أمراض مزمنة وقاربوا على الوفاة
كل شيء بدمهم يصير يضطرب، ومن ضمنها الكوليسترول
فبيقل الكوليسترول عندهم كثير
بس مش معناه أن الكوليسترول المنخفض جيد
لأن عندهم أمراض معينة قللت الكوليسترول
بس لما نشوف للدراسات السريرية
بنشوف أن لما نقلل نسبة كوليسترول الدم
بتقل نسب الإصابة بأمراض القلب والشرايين
بس الدراسات اللي بتقارن بين كل العوامل اللي حكينا عنها
تصلب الشرايين ومقاومة الإنسولين مع الاصابة بأمراض القلب
بنشوف أن الكوليسترول مهم، بس مش أهم شيء
أهم شيء اللي لازم نحكي عنه هو مقاومة الإنسولين أو اضطربات الأيض
لأن مقاومة الإنسولين من الأشياء اللي برضه تبدأ في بدايات العمر
في العشرنيات والثلاثينات ممكن تبدأ
كلما زاد الاضطراب بالآخر راح يوصل لشيء مثل السكري من النوع الثاني
بس هذه التغيرات بتبدأ على شكل تغيرات طفيفة في تنظيم سكر الدم
عشان نفهم الموضوع
سكر الدم بيدخل إلى الخلايا عشان يتم استهلاكه
كطاقة ولتنفيذ العمليات الحيوية داخل الخلية
بس سكر الدم ما بيقدر يدخل إلى الخلية لوحده
بيحتاج نفتح ممرات داخل جدران الخلية
وعشان تفتح هذه الممرات، نحتاج شيء آخر اسمه الإنسولين
اللي هو هرمون ينفرز من البنكرياس
هذا الهرمون بينفرز استجابةً لارتفاع الجلوكوز اللي هو سكر الدم
عشان يفتح هذه الممرات ويدخل السكر إلى الخلايا
بس مقاومة الإنسولين هي لما نحتاج نسبة أعلى من الإنسولين
لفتح نفس عدد الممرات
فالخلايا بتكون مقاومة للإنسولين، ما بتستجيب للإنسولين بشكل سريع
وهذه من التغيرات المبكرة اللي بتصير
اللي بتؤدي إلى اضطراب تنظيم سكر الدم
فبالبداية بنشوف حاجة أكبر للإنسولين
للمحافظة على نفس درجة سكر الدم
عشان كذا لما تفحص سكر الدم مثلًا ويكون طبيعي
مش معناه أن ما عندك أي نوع من أنواع مقاومة الإنسولين
لأنك لازم تشوف كمان إنسولين الصيام، درجة الإنسولين في الدم
وهذه من الفحوصات اللي مش كثير تنعمل
بالفحوصات الطبية بشكل عام للناس الأصحاء
أنا بعملها لأن بحسها مهمة
وفيه بعض الأطباء بيختلفوا معي فيها
بس إذا عندك ارتفاع في الإنسولين، وسكر الدم طبيعي
هذا يمكن يكون مؤشر على بداية مقاومة الإنسولين
ولو أنك فحصت سكر الدم لوحده
ما بتعرف أن عندك بدايات مقاومة الإنسولين
فمفترض أنك تسوي فحص للاثنين؟
لمقاومة الإنسولين و...؟
بالضبط، أنا بفضل سكر الدم مع إنسولين الصيام
فسكر الصيام مع إنسولين الصيام
ونستعملهم في حساب معين؛ بيعطيك تقدير لمقاومة الإنسولين
شيء اسمه الـ«هوما آي آر»
طيب وفكرة أنك تحط الجهاز وتخليه معك
عشرة أيام أو أربعة عشر يوم تشوف أدائك، مامدى فائدته؟
أول شيء خلينا نحكي عن الأدلة العلمية
للناس الأصحاء الأدلة العلمية بتشير أنه مش كثير مفيد
وما بيؤدي إلى نتائج صحية أفضل
بس أنا استخدمته وكثير ناس اللي استخدموه
ساعدهم في أن يفهموا علاقتهم مع الأكل
فتشوف وين الإرتفاعات تصير؟
بس فيه مشكلة
أيش هي؟
المشكلة هي أن احنا نركز على قياس واحد للصحة
اللي هو سكر الدم، فنصير نحاول نحسن هذا القياس
بس ممكن نهمل قياسات أخرى ما بنقيسها
مثلًا، لو آكل أنا صحن من الزبدة
ما راح يرتفع عندي سكر الدم على القياس
بس هل معناه أن اللي أكلته شيء صحي؟ لا
بس لأن ما بقيس دهون الدم والأشياء الثانية اللي تتغير في الدم
فهذه المشكلة دائمًا لما نقيس شغلة وحدة ونركز على شغلة وحدة
فإذا كان عندنا الفهم الصحيح ممكن نستعمل الـ«سي جي إم»
اللي هو مراقبة الجلوكوز المستمر بشكل مفيد
طيب مخفضات الكوليسترول؟
مخفضات الكوليسترول بالبداية أكثر دواء شائع
لتخفيض الكوليسترول هو «الإستاتنز»
«الإستاتنز» هذه عليها شوية مشاكل
فيه ناس ما بيحبوها، ليش؟
لأن فيه نسبة صغيرة من الناس بيصيبهم أعراض جانبية
سيئة من «الإستاتنز» وهي ممكن تأثر على عضلات الجسم
تؤدي إلى تكسير العضلات في بعض الأحيان
وتؤدي إلى آلام في العضلات
عشان كذا لما الوحد يبدأ على الأدوية الخافضة للكوليسترول
إذا صار عنده هذه الأعراض الجانبية
ممكن نغيّر «الإستاتنز» لأدوية أخرى
بس اللي كنت بحكيه أن مش بس «الإستاتنز» هو الحل الوحيد
فيه ناس بياخذوا «الإستاتنز» وبيصير عندهم هذه الأعراض الجانبية
ويقول لك: خلاص، خلِّ الكوليسترول مرتفع، ما أبغى آخذ هذا الدواء
بس فيه أدوية أخرى ممكن تساعد
ما أبغى أحكي أسماء أدوية وأدخل بهذا الموضوع
الواحد لازم يستشير طبيب
بس مهم أن ناخذ موضوع الكوليسترول بشكل جدي
حتى لو صار عندنا أعراض جانبية من بعض الأدوية
فيه أدوية أخرى بتساعد
وتشوف إلى أن تصل للدواء اللي يناسبك
اللي يناسبك بالضبط
الحين هذه بالنسبة للشرايين
حكينا عن الكوليسترول، وحكينا عن ضغط الدم
حكينا شوي عن مقاومة الإنسولين
ما حكينا كيف نحسن مقاومة الإنسولين
بس حكينا كيف نقيسها عن طريق سكر الدم والإنسولين
وبالمناسبة، حساس السكر هذا ممكن نستخدمه
في فحص ثاني ما بينعمل كثير مخبريًّا
بينعمل عند الحوامل
بس برضه أعتقد أنه مفيد عند أي أحد
نسميه اختبار تحمل الجلوكوز، اللي هو أيش؟
نعطيك جرعة من الجلوكوز، أعتقد بيكون 75 قرام من سكر
وبنقيس سكر الدم تبعك بعد ثلاثين دقيقة وبعد ساعة وبعد ساعتين
وبنشوف كيف يتغير مع الزمن
وهذا قياس حساس جدًّا لمقاومة الإنسولين
حتى ممكن نقيس الإنسولين كمان مع السكر
يورّينا كيف يتعامل جسمنا مع سكر الدم
ففيه شركات الحين بتستعمل جهاز قياس السكر المستمر
بأنها تعمل شيء مشابه
بيعطوك شيء تاكله، بعدين بتشوف كيف يتغير سكر الدم تبعك
وهذا الشيء بيعطيك مؤشر
إذا عندك إضطرابات أولية في تنظيم سكر الدم
وبما أنك باقي في سكر الدم
كيف تحسن من مقاومة الإنسولين؟
أول شغلة هي تخفيض نسبة الدهون
وعادةً الدهون الحشوية مرتبطة بشكل كبير بمقاومة الإنسولين
ليه؟ لأن الدهون الحشوية بتدخل في أعضاء جسمنا
بتدخل برضه في الأنسجة العضلية وداخل الخلية
فيه دراسات بتقول: أن لما الواحد بيكون عنده دهون حشوية عالية
أنواع من الدهون تكون مرتفعة داخل الخلية
وهذا شيء مرتبط بشكل مباشر بمقاومة الإنسولين
فكأنها بتمنع دخول الإنسولين
ما بعرف الطريقة الميكانيكية، بس مرتبطين بشكل كبير ببعض
كيف ممكن نعمل هذا الشيء؟
بنزيد الكتلة العضلية
الكتلة العضلية محرقة للسعرات الحرارية ومحرقة للدهون
فالكتلة العضلية العالية بتزيد من حساسية الإنسولين بشكل عام
وبتقلل من الدهون الحشوية
والمحافظة على وزن جيد
فهذه أول شغلة
بعدين ممكن نستعمل أدوية معينة
للناس اللي عندهم مقاومة الإنسولين
فيه أدوية بتساعد فيه تنظيم سكر الدم
مثل مساعد السكري الـ«متفورمين»
فيه له حالات خاصة، مش دائمًا هو الحل
وحتى فيه دراسة جديدة قالت: أنه كمعدل ما بيقلل
من أن الحالة تصير أسوأ من ما قبل السكري إلى السكري
بس في بعض الحالات بيساعد
في تحسين مقاومة الإنسولين وتنظيم سكر الدم
هذا الدواء اسمه «متفورمين» دواء كثير مشهور بعالم التقدم في العمر
لأن فيه دراسة طلعت عليه قبل سنين
بتقول: أن الناس اللي بياخذوا «متفورمين» مساعد السكري يسمى أحيانًا
بيعيشوا أطول من الناس اللي ما بياخذوه
مع أن الناس اللي بياخذوه معهم سكري ومعهم أمراض مزمنة
بس فيه دراسة أخرى نقضت هذا الشيء، فعليه جدل شوي
بس فيه أدوية أخرى ممكن ناخذها
من ضمنها اللي جديد بتطلع هي أدوية التنحيف، أدوية السمنة
اللي بتقلل من مقاومة الإنسولين
وبتحسن علامات تنظيم سكر الدم
وبتحسن من الوزن بشكل عام
مثل الـ«أوزمبك» والـ«مونوجارو» اللي كثير منتشر الآن
كأن الـ«أوزمبك» والـ«ويقوفيو»
هم من نفس الشيء بس بجرعات مختلفة
حاليًا أكثر دواء نجاحًا بتاريخ البشرية
واو!
فيه تقرير طلع من «وول مارت» سلسلة الأسواق بأمريكا
حكوا أنه قلّت مبيعاتهم بسبب الـ«أوزمبك»
الناس بتاكل أقل
صح، بس ما أدري أيش مشاكله على الجهة الأخرى
لأنك أنت بتضطر تاخذه مدى حياتك؟
ما عليه دراسات مدى الحياة، بس عليه دراسات لحد سنتين
ويبدو أنه آمن جدًّا، وبيساعد فعلًا في تقليل الوزن
أنا بستعمله مع مرضى وبشوف أنه بيساعد كثير
ومن الأشياء الجانبية اللي بلاحظها
أنه بيقلل الرغبة، يعني بتقل مشاكل مثلًا الاعتماد على التدخين
الاعتماد على الكحول مع هذه الأدوية
فعليًّأ تأثيرها قوي
رهيب والله
بس صار فيه مشكلة أنه لما تبطل تاخذ هذه الأدوية
أنك بترجع
يرد يزيد الوزن بس ما بيرجع لنفس الدرجة
بيرجع 60% من اللي خسرته، فبيكون خسرت 30%، حلوين
حلوين، بس لو أنت تضبط نمط الحياة حقك بشكل أفضل
بتمارس الرياضة وتاكل أكل صحي
بالحالة المثالية، وكلنا بنعرف أن هذه الأشياء مهمة
بس ما أحد بيعملها
بس لما تنزل وزنك بأنك قللت، هو أفضل من أنك تقعد
هذه الأدوية بتساعد هي مثل شيء نرتكز عليه
بيساعدنا نضبط حياتنا عن طريقة التغذية والرياضة
فيه دراسات بتقول أن
بأي تدخل طبي بيخفّض الوزن حتى بالحمية الغذائية
راح يقل جزء من خسارة الوزن هذا
راح يكون خسارة في الكتلة العضلية
فهذا شيء نبغى نتفاداه
بس مع هذه الأدوية الخسارة بالكتلة العضلية ممكن تكون أكبر
من خسارة الكتلة العضلية من الحمية
فعشان كذا مهم أن اللي بياخذوا هذه الأدوية
يحافظوا على رياضات المقاومة ويتناولوا بروتين بشكل كافي
الحين تصلب الشرايين هو نفسه الجلطات، السكتات القلبية
وللا فيه فروقات بين كل شيء، وللا هي بس مجرد...؟
تصلب الشرائين بيؤدي إلى الجلطات
لأنه بيصير مثل ما حكينا
تخيل أنت الشريان بيصير متصلب؛ فبيقل تدفق الدم داخل الشريان
لأنه بيصير أصغر وأصغر
وبعدين في النهاية أحيانًا يصير فيه تكسّر بجزء من الشريان المتصلب
وهذا الجزء يسد الشريان اللي بيؤدي لهذه الجلطة
عشان كذا الجلطة بتصير بشكل مفاجئ
وبيصير فيه انكسار ويصير فيه انسداد
وبتنقطع تروية الدم لجزء من القلب
فتموت عضلة القلب وهذا الشيء يؤدي للوفاة
فهنا يحتاج الشخص تدخل طارئ
بيروح الواحد إلى القسطرة وبيحطوا شبكة عشان تفتح هذه المنطقة
هل ممكن أشعر بهذه الأشياء؟
هل ممكن أي شيء يخليني أعرف
أن فيه شريان بدأ يخرب، غير أني أفحص؟
لما تتطور الشغلة؛ بيصير أحيان فيه أعراض عند بعض الناس
وهذا الشيء بيدخل بتخصص القلب مش تخصصي
بس بيصير فيه ألم في الصدر
فيه ناس مثلًا وهو بيطلع درج مثلًا يصير عنده ألم في الصدر
هذه من العلامات الطارئة، لازم تروح تشوف طبيب
إذا عندك ألم في الصدر مع الحركة وإستهلاك الجهد
هذا الشيء خطير، لازم تشوف طبيب لما يصير عندك هذه الأعراض
وفيه أعراض أخرى مثل: الدوخة والتعب مع أي جهد
الدوخة متى؟
أحيانًا يصير فيه نقص تروية للدماغ، فهذه من الأشياء المهمة
بالمناسبة، مش بس فحوصات الدم
اللي تساعدنا نعرف هذه الأشياء
برضه فيه فحوصات مخبرية مثل صور أشعة مقطعية
وفيه شيء اسمه تصنيف الكالسيوم
اللي هو صورة أشعة مقطعية بتشوف الكالسيوم في جدران الأوعية
لأن هذا الشيء مصاحب لتصلب الشرايين
وهذا الشيء يعطينا برضه فكرة عن درجة تصلب الشرايين
إذا ما فيه كالسيوم مو معناه أن ما فيه تصلب شرايين
إذا بيكون تصنيف الكالسيوم مرتفع
هذا الشيء بيعطينا فكرة أن فيه تصلب شرايين
وفيه برضه فحوصات أخرى مثل القسطرة وما إلى ذلك
طيب مامدى فعلًا هذا الكالسيوم؟
هل فيه إشارات، مثلًا يقول لك أن هذا الكالسيوم أقل؟
أعتقد هذه مش حقيقية
مش حقيقية؟ يا أخي أنا أمتحنوني، أحس أني آخذ كالسيوم كثير
بس كل مرة تشوفه أمي تقول: يا أخي اشرب حليب
الحين تكلمنا عن أمراض القلب اللي هي الأعلى تأثيرًا على الناس
أو من الأمراض القاتلة للبشرية
يجي تحتها السرطان؟
السرطان
السرطان أيش هو؟
السرطان هو عبارة عن خلايا متمردة عن محيطها
الخلايا الطبيعية الجسم بيتحكم فيها
إذا بتحتاج نمو؛ الجسم بيرسل لها إشارات معينة أنه بنحتاج نمو
مثلًا لما تنجرح أنت؛ الخلايا تلتئم عن طريق النمو بصورة طبيعية
بس الخلايا السرطانية ما تلتزم بهذه الإشارات
بتصير تنمو بشكل عشوائي
السرطان هو عالم من الأمراض، مش بس مرض واحد
كل أنسجة الجسم ممكن تتحول لخلايا سرطانية
فعشان كذا أنواع السرطان كثير
برضه درجة السرطان شغلة مهمة
والسرطان من الأشياء اللي ممكن مختلفة شوي عن أمراض القلب
لأنه مش من الأشياء اللي بتبدأ بعمر صغير وتتطور مع الوقت
هي مرتبطة بالتقدم في العمر
أكبر عامل مسبب أو مرتبط بالإصابة بالسرطان هو التقدم في العمر
هناك حالات خاصة في السرطانات بتصيب الأطفال طبعًا
بس معظم أنواع السرطان بتصيبنا مع التقدم في العمر
ما في أشياء كثير نعملها عشان نقلل نسبة إصابتنا بالسرطان
عشان كذا بالنسبة للسرطان وتفاديه
اللي يمكن مهم جدًّا هو الكشف المبكر
خلينا نحكي شوي عن الأشياء الحياتية
المرتبطة بتقليل الإصابة بالسرطان
أول شيء، الامتناع عن التدخين
التدخين هو أكبر المسببات للسرطان
والمشكلة قلّت نسبة التدخين عالميًّا خلال العقود الماضية
بس الحين بترتفع خاصة بالفئات العمرية الصغيرة
من وراء السجائر الإلكترونية
فهذا الشيء يُنذر على أنه راح يكون فيه ارتفاع مستقبلًا بسرطان الرئة
الله يعين
كمان الرياضة بشكل عام
بتقلل من نسبة إصابتنا بكثير أنواع من السرطان
الجمعية الأمريكية للطب الرياضي
تحكي أن فيه سبع نواع من السرطان مرتبطة
بشكل مباشر بالرياضة وزيادة الرياضة
عن 150 دقيقة أسبوعيًّا من الرياضة المتوسطة الحدة
تحمينا من سبع أنواع شائعة من السرطان أوبتقلل من نسبة حدوثها
أنت المشي تشوفه مو رياضة صح؟
هو جزء من الرياضة
المشي وتفادي الخمول بشكل عام هو قاعدة أساسية
بعدين بنبي عليها الأنواع المختلفة من الرياضة اللي حكينا عنها مسبقًا
شيء ثالث؟
مقاومة الإنسولين والسمنة برضه مرتبطة بالإصابة ببعض السرطان
واللي من أهمها سرطان الرحم مثلًا
أنا تخصصي الدقيق هو السرطان
بنشوف عند النساء اللي عندهم سرطان الرحم
نسبة كبيرة منهم هم نساء سمينات عندهم وزن زائد
فهذا الشيء مرتبط بشكل مباشر
بزيادة الإصابة بكثير أنواع من السرطان
فهذه الأشياء ممكن نعملها بتحمينا نوعًا ما من السرطان بشكل عام
إضافةً إلى ذلك عشان نحمي حالنا من السرطان
لازم نهتم بالكشف المبكر
عمرك كشفت؟
أنا لا، لأن عمري صغير نوعًا ما
لكن الكشف المبكر متعلق بحسب نوع
لأن حكينا أنواع الأمراض اللي بتصيبنا مع التقدم في العمر صنفناها
بس داخل السرطان فيه كمان تصنيف للسرطانات
فيه سرطانات شائعة، فيه سرطانات أقل شيوعًا
السرطانات الشائعة هي: الرئة، البرستات عند الرجال، الثدي عند النساء،
سرطان القولون، وبعدين فيه أنواع أخرى من السرطان أقل شيوعًا
الكشف المبكر بيتم حسب نوع السرطان
فإذا الشخص مدخن لازم يعمل كشف مبكر عن سرطان الرئتين
عن طريق صورة الأشعة العادية للصدر
الأشعة السينية؟
الأشعة السينية، ممكن تورينا
بيختلف حسب الدول وحسب برامج الكشف المبكر؛ بتختلف التوصيات
فبعطي توصيات عامة
بس مهم الواحد يشوف أيش التوصيات الموجودة في منطقته
حكينا عن سرطان الرئة، بس أهم شيء نعمله لسرطان الرئة
هو أن نتفادى التدخين
والتدخين مرتبط بكل الأمراض اللي حكينا عنها
الأمراض الأيضية، القلبية والسرطان
بعدين حكينا عن سرطانات أخرى مثل السرطان الثدي
مهم جدًّا الكشف المبكر عند النساء
عن طريق صور «الماموقرام» وكمان أنواع أخرى من الصور
حسب خطر الإصابة تبع السيدة
الكشف مبكر للسرطان عند الأنثى
والكشف المبكر عن سرطان البروستات عند الرجل برضه
عن طريق فحص دم بسيط، شيء اسمه الـ «البي إس إيه»
هو بروتين في الدم بيرتفع مع الإصابة بسرطان البروستات
وبنشوف الدرجة تبعته وبرضه درجة التغير مع الزمن
بس البروستات حالة خاصة شوي
لأنه سرطان البروستات كثير مرتبط بالتقدم في العمر
ونسبة عالية من الرجال راح يصيبهم سرطان البروستات
بس مش معناه أنه راح يتوفوا من سرطان البروستات
كثير من الناس بيكون عندهم بعض الخلايا السرطانية
لما يتقدموا في العمر
بس مش معناه أنه دائمًا لازم يدخلوا بعلاج السرطان
اللي نسمع عنه الكيماوي والأشياء هذه
وممكن نحكي شوي عن علاجات السرطان
إيه، هل كل السرطانات علاجها بهذه الحدية؟
لا
عادي ممكن مثلًا مثل سرطان ببرستات ممكن تعالجه بعلاج عادي؟
أحيانًا ممكن ما نعالجه أصلًا
وما يموّتك؟
مش دائمًا خاصة سرطان البروستات
إذا شفناه تحت المايكروسكوب وكان محصور بمنطقة بعينة
عادةً بنستخرجه ونعمل عملية
أحيانًا فيه استراتيجية شاهد وانتظر
بنراقبه كل فترة بنعمل الفحص وبنشوف إذا بيتغير
إذا صار يتغير بشكل سريع؛ ممكن نتدخل علاجيًّا
بس بشكل عام فيه ثلاث تصنيفات لعلاجات السرطان
القطع، الحرق، والسم
القطع اللي هو الجراحة، نستأصل الورم
الحرق عن طريق
بحكي حرق بس أنا قصدي العلاج بالأشعة
اللي هو مثل الأشعة العادية اللي بنعرفها
الأشعة المقطعية وأشعة الصدر مثلًا
نفسها بس بنركزها بجرعة كثير عالية بمنطقة الورم نفسه
هذا هو التخصص الدقيق تبعي
فبنركز الأشعة بمنطقة الورم وبندمر الخلايا السرطانية
وهذا عالم
بعدين فيه العلاجات، أنا سميتها السم، اللي هي العلاجات الكيماوية
وبعدين فيه العلاجات الأحدث
اللي هي العلاجات المستهدفة
اللي تستهدف الأنواع معينة من السرطان
فيه علاجات هرمونية
مثلًا سرطان البروستات بيتغذى على «التستسترون»
فالشخاص اللي عندهم سرطان البروستات
في كثير من الأحيان بنعطيهم أدوية بتثبّط «التستسترون»
ونفس الشيء في السرطان الثدي
في كثير من الأحيان نعطيهم أدوية تخفض «الإستروجين»
اللي هي هرمونات الأنثوية
وتحل المشكلة بدون تدخل؟
أيوة، أو بتكون هي علاج مساعد في معظم الأحيان
حديثًا فيه كمان في العلاجات المناعية
اللي بتنشط الجهاز المناعي تبعنا أن يستهدف للسرطان
وهذا تطور كبير صار آخر فترة في علاجات السرطان
وجود السرطان ليس بالضرورة أن علاجه كيماوي وعلاجه معقد
ممكن فيه علاجات بسيطة له؟
فيه كثير من الحالات بيكون بس علاج جراحي
ممكن نعطي علاج آخر بعد العلاج الجراحي
بيقلل من نسبة رجوع السرطان
وإعادة تنشيط الخلايا السرطانية
رغم أن الناس أحس أن أكثر شيء يربكهم هو السرطان
والحين الدراسات أو الأبحاث تقول: أن هو ثاني مسبب للوفاة في العالم
إلا أنك تقول برضه... لنفترض أنهم اخترعوا علاج بكرة
قادر على علاج السرطان مباشرةً
وأنه بيزيد عمر الإنسان بمعدل ثلاث إلى خمس سنين فقط
كل هذه الدوشة بس علشان ثلاث أو أربع سنين؟
لا هي مش كذا، احنا لما نحكي عنها كمعدل
فعلًا فيه دراسة حلوة على هذا الموضوع
عُملت بالتسعينيات، بس شافوا أنه لو عالجنا السرطان بعد ما يحدث
كمعدل احنا ما بنزيد أعمار البشرية أكثر من ثلاث إلى خمس سنين
بس الشخص نفسه لما ينصاب بيختلف
أنا لو أنصاب بالسرطان بكرة، وبعدين تم علاجي منه
على أغلب معدل عمري راح يزيد أكثر من ثلاث إلى خمس سنين
فأنا بحكي عن معدل
والهدف هنا من أن نعالج المرض بعد حدوثه
هو أن نمنع حدوثه بالأساس
فهذا الشيء ممكن بشكل أكبر بأمراض القلب والأمراض الأيضية
إلى حد أقل ممكن بالسرطان، لأن ما بنعرف كيف نمنعه لحد الآن
فعشان كذا الكشف المبكر مهم
وفيه شغلة مهمة أن وحدة من الفحوصات والتدخلات الطبية
الكثير ناجحة في الكشف المبكر
ومنع تكوّن إحدى أنواع السرطان اللي هو سرطان القولون
هو التنظير
التنظير اللي هو ندخل على القولون وبيشوف الطبيب
وبيستأصل الأورام أو التغيرات المبكرة في القولون
تخيل سرطان القولون هو سرطان شائع نوعًا ما
99% من الحالات يمكن تفاديها
بالكشف المبكر؟
بالكشف المبكر
واو!
بأمريكا التوصيات هي أن أي شخص أعتقد بعد سن الخمسة وأربعين
لازم يعمل تنظير
بس معظم الناس، 65% من الناس
اللي ممكن يعملوا بتنظيره؛ ما بيعملوه وهو متاح لهم
وفي معظم الدول فيه برامج الكشف المبكر
بس معظم الناس ما تقدم عليها
فمفروض في الحالة المثالية أن ما أحد ينصاب بسرطان القولون
وحدة من السرطانات اللي بس تتقدم
علاجها سيء جدًّا، لأنه بيتم استئصال جزء كبير من القولون
والمشاكل الحياتية اللي بعدين في كثير من الأحيان سيئة جدًّا
ورغم أن كان فيه احتمالية كبيرة لتفاديه؟ واو!
كبيرة جدًّا
الله يعين يارب
بتسمع عن مراحل السرطان، المرحلة الرابعة
أيش معنى هذه المراحل؟
هي لما يكون السرطان في المرحلة الأولى
عادة بنصنف السرطان بشكل مبسط على أربع مراحل
المرحلة الأولى هو لسه بس تغيّر خلايا معينة في مكانها
بعدين ينتشر شوي؛ بتصير المرحلة الثانية
انتشر أكثر شوي؛ المرحلة الثالثة
وبعدين المرحلة الرابعة ينتشر في مكان بعيد عن مكان نشوء السرطان،
فمثلًا إذا كان سرطان بالثدي وانتشر إلى الكبد
هذا يعتبر انتشار بعيد، وهذا يعتبر مرحلة الأخيرة أو الرابعة
لأن ما في مرحلة خامسة
هنا يصعب جدًّا علاج السرطان، بس بالمراحل المبكرة لا
هو بالعكس نجاح العلاج عالي
تقريبًا 50% من حالات السرطان بشكل عام يتم الشفاء منها
هذه نسبة كثير الناس ما بيعرفوها
وكم تاخذ عادةً المدة من المرحلة الأولى إلى المرحلة الرابعة؟
ممكن تاخذ أشهر وممكن تاخذ سنين
حسب نوع السرطان وحسب الشخص
وعادةً تنصح بأن يبدأ الواحد يكشف من بعد الاربعين وللا؟
هو الكشف المبكر حسب خطر الإصابة
فإذا فيه ناس عندهم تغيرات جينية أو زيادة خطر الإصابة وراثيًّا
يحتاجوا يكشفوا بعمر أبكر
فيفضل الواحد يتبع التعليمات المحلية تبعه
بس فيه فحوصات من جديد بتطلع هي فحوصات دم
ممكن تكشف عن وجود السرطان في الجسم بشكل مبكر
لسه ما تمت دراستها بشكل كامل
بس عليها دراسات كبيرة الحين في بريطانيا وأمريكا
وبتظهر نتائج أولية جيدة
اللي هي تخيل فحص دم بسيط
بيفحص المادة الوراثية تبع الخلية
الحين الخلايا السراطانية فيها مادة وراثية جينات مثل كل الخلايا الأخرى
بس الخلايا السرطانية عشوائية جدًّا
وبتتسرب منها محتوياتها
فالمادة الوراثية تبع الخلية السرطانية ممكن تتسرب للدم
وبتكون موجودة في دمنا
فممكن نعمل فحص دم بسيط
يكشف عن وجود المادة الوراثية السرطانية
ويعطينا إشارة ويعطينا فكرة أن فيه خلايا سرطانية في جسمنا
لأن بنحتاج تقريبًا -ناسي كم العدد- يمكن مثل مليون خلية
عشان يظهر الورم في صورة الأشعة المقطعية
لو قدرنا نكشف عن وجود الخلايا السرطانية قبل ما تكبر
لما يكون فيه عدد صغير
بيكون علاجها أسهل وأسهل
بيكون علاجها أسهل، لأن مثل ما حكينا
كلما كشفنا مبكرًا عن وجود السرطان، كلما كان علاجه أنجح
كذا قفلنا ملف السرطان وللا باقي نقطة؟
يمكن الفكرة اللي أبغى أحكيها
أن كلنا بنكوّن خلايا سرطانية بشكل مستمر
كلنا بيصير فينا خلايا سرطانية
بس الأجسام الصحية والأجسام اللي مناعتها جيدة
تكشف عن وجود هذا السرطان، وبتعالجك منه تلقائيًّا
فممكن يجي سرطان أو خلايا سرطانية والجسم يعالجها تلقائيًّا؟
هذا الشيء بيصير فيّ وفيك بشكل مستمر
بس مع التقدم في العمر بتقل قدرتنا على هذا الشيء
أحيانًا بتظهر خلايا سرطانية وبتتغلب على المناعة تبعنا
وتتغلب على جسمنا وبيصير عندنا مرض سرطان
الله يكفينا الشر
الآن الأمراض العصبية، وهي برضه من الأمراض
اللي تقتل جزء من الناس وعدد كبير من الناس
4% من الوفيات يكونوا بسبب أمراض عصبية
أتوقع من الأشياء اللي تقلق الناس منها ويخيفها اللي هو الزهايمر
لو نبدأ نتكلم عن الأمراض العصبية
وحدة من الأمراض المتعلقة بالتقدم في العمر
وهنا بنحكي عن الخرف والمسبب الأساسي لهذا المرض هو الزهايمر
وبرضه الزهايمر بيبدأ مش عمر بدري مثلًا الثلاثينات والأربعينات
متأخر شوي، بس بيبدأ يتكوّن شوي شوي
فممكن نكشف عنه مبكرًا
مشكلة هذه الأمراض أن التدخلات الطبية
اللي ممكن نستعملها لتقليل الإصابة فيها
يمكن أقل شوي أو مشابهة شوي للسرطان
حتى لو كشفنا عن وجودها
التدخلات الطبية مش كثير ناجحة إلى الآن لإبطاء تقدمها
بس الأشياء اللي ممكن نعملها هي الأشياء اللي الأساسية
اللي هي الرياضة مثلًا مرتبطة بشكل كبير بتقليل نسبة الإصابة
مقاومة الإنسولين
فيه ناس بيسموا الخرف، السكري من النوع الثالث
لأنه مرتبط بشكل كبير باضطراب تنظيم سكر الدم
فإذا بنحافظ على سكر الدم جيد، وأيض جيد
هذا الشيء بيقينا بشكل كبير من الإصابة بالخرف والزهايمر
والوزن الجيد والأشياء هذه
وفيه فحوصات
فيه ناس عندهم قابلية جينية للإصابة بالخرف والزهايمر أكثر من غيرهم
وكتبت تغريدة عن هذا الموضوع قبل فترة
وهاجموني بعض الزملاء، لأني حكيت عن هذا الموضوع
لأن فيه فحص جيني ممكن نعمله
يكشف عن وجود تغيرات جينية معينة
جين اسمه الـ «إيبو إي»
كلنا عندنا هذا الجين، بس فيه أنواع مختلفة منه
فيه «إيبو إي 2» و «إيبو إي 3» و«إيبو إي 4»
الناس الذين لديهم نسخة أو نسختين من «إيبو إي 4»
قابلية إصابتهم بالخرف أعلى كثير من غيرهم
حتى لما نشوف أدمغتهم بالصور المقطعية
أدمغتهم أصغر، بمعنى الضمور بيكون أسرع من أدمغة الناس الآخرين
أيش كان مأخذهم عليك؟
كان مأخذهم علي أنه بشجع الناس يعملوا هذا الفحص
بالآخر هو راح يؤدي للقلق
ما في دليل واضح
لا، مش أن ما في دليل؛ ما في تدخل بتقدر تعمله
مش فعّال، ما راح يؤدي لدواء معين مثلًا يقلل الإصابة
هو حقيقي، وكان ردي أن أنا ما بشجع الناس أن يعملوه
بس فيه ناس بتسألني أنا أبغى أعرف إذا عندي قابلية أو لا
زائدة أو لا عن الآخرين
فإذا حابب تعرف؛ من الفحوصات اللي ممكن تعملها هذا الفحص
بس إذا تبغى تعمله؛ لازم تكون عارف إذا عندك هذا الجين
وعندك نسبة إصابة زائدة
الأشياء اللي راح تعملها هي مشابهة لأي شخص ثاني
هي الرياضة والأكل الجيد والمحافظة على وزن جيد
فهي ممكن تعطيك دافع أنك تحافظ على أسلوب حياة جيد
لأن عندك نسبة إصابة زائدة
بس كمان شغلة الناس ما بيفهموها بالقابلية الجينية
مش معناه أن عندك قابلية جينية لشيء معين
معناته راح يصيبك 100%
هي بس شغلة نسب
عندك نسبة يمكن أعلى شوي من الآخرين
مش معناه أن حتمًا راح يصيبك هذا الشيء
وفكرة أني أنسى، هل هي دلالة
حتى لو كنت في الثلاثينات أو في العشرينات؛ أن هذا زهايمر؟
لا، التشخيص بالخرف له طرق معينة للتشخيص
شغلة النسيان الطبيعي عادي
بس إذا صارت الشغلة تأثر على الوظائف اليومية
فيه أسئلة معينة ممكن نسألها للشخص
عشان نكشف عن وجود نسيان مرضي
صعب الواحد يصنف حاله إذا عنده خرف أو لا
مثل أيش الأسئلة؟
فيه كثير أدوات بنستعملها
وحدة منهم بنسألك مثلًا
أيش تاريخ اليوم؟ وين أنت وفي أي مكان؟
أشياء مثل كذا أشياء أساسية
إذا الشخص عنده مشاكل بهذه الأشياء
هذا الشيء بيخلينا نعتقد بأن احتمال كبير يكون عنده نسيان مرضي
بس فيه فحوصات أعمق شوي اسمها «الفحص العصبي المعرفي»
هي أسئلة رياضية، وأشكال معينة بتصنفها بطرق معينة وتقلدها
فهذا الشيء يعطيك فكرة أعمق
وفيه الحين فحوصات على التابلت تنعمل
تعطيك مثلًا صور سريعة ويسألك عنها وتقيس حركتك
وهذه الأشياء تعطيك دلائل أولية
على وجود انخفاض في القدرة العقلية مش الخرف
خلينا نحكي بدايات الخرف
بس النسيان مو مرتبط أبدًا ومو دلالة على الخرف
النسيان حتى الزايد
خلينا نحكي، الخرف مرتبط بالنسيان
بس النسيان مش دائمًا مرتبط بالخرف
حتى لو كنت تنسى أكثر
لأن فيه ناس تنسى أكثر، وفيه ناس ذاكرتهم جيدة
مرتبط برضه إذا أنت نايم تمام، مش شارب قهوة
هذه الأشياء بتأثر على التركيز والنسيان بشكل عام
والكشف عنها مبكرًا ما له أي قيمة ثانية يبدوا لي
لأن ما يمدك تعالجه
حسب الشخص، فيه ناس يحبوا يعرفوا، وفيه ناس ما بيحبوا يعرفوا
لا، أنا أحس مشكلة والله
هو مش دقيق جدًّا
ما في فحص راح يعطيك 100% أنك أنت راح تنصاب بهذا الشيء
الله يسهل يا رب
وطيب هل فيها تمارين أو أشياء معينة
أو حتى مكملات غذائية تساعد الإنسان يخلي ذاكرته أفضل؟
الرياضة بشكل عام بتؤدي إلى إفراز شيء اسمه «بي دي إن إف»
هو بروتين ينفرز في الدماغ، ومخصص بشكل كبير بالرياضة
فصعب الحصول عليه بدون ما نمارس الرياضة
وهذا الشيء بيحمي الوصلات العصبية
قالوا بالدراسات أنه بيأثر بشكل مباشر
بالوصلات العصبية وبزيد قوتها
فالرياضة لا بد منها
المقاومة وللا الكارديو؟
كل أنواع الرياضة
كل أنواع الرياضة؟
بس الكارديو بشكل خاص
أعتقد كمان المقاومة، وكل أنواع الرياضة
بتزيد من إفراز هذا البروتين
كمكملات غذائية: زيت السمك مرتبط شوي بالحماية العصبية
وبالأخص إذا حصلنا عليه من مصادر طبيعية
مثلًا: السالمون والأسماك الغنية بزيوت السمك
ممكن نحصل عليها من المكملات الغذائية برضه
فيه واحد من علماء الأعصاب المتخصصين بهذا المجال
هو حكى لي أن هو بينصح الحصول عليها من مصادر طبيعية
وبيعتقد أن الحصول عليها من المكملات الغذائية غير كافي
بينصح أن الواحد يتناول أسماك غنية بالزيوت مرتين أسبوعيًّا على الأقل
وأنت في الرياض، السمك تطلعه من الجبل
طيب، فيه شيء ثاني تتوقع أنه ما تكلمنا عنه مع أنه كان مهم؟
شيء يزيد التركيز، القهوة
والله؟
أيوة القهوة
فيه كثير ناس يسألوا عن أيش فيه مكمل غذائي يخليني أركز أكثر؟
معظم المكملات الغذائية اللي بتزيد تركيز تبعك
هي فعليًّا بتحتوي على كافيين
«الماتشا» مفيد؟
«الماتشا»؟
إيه
ما بعرف صراحة، يمكن فيه شوية كافيين وللا لا
ما أعرف والله، هم يشربوه ويقولوا أنه مفيد
أو الـ«بي 12» معظم الناس بتفكر إنه إذا بيتناول منه
فهذا الشيء بيقوّي الذاكرة
بس هذا الشيء إذا كان عندك نقص
ومعظم الناس ما عندهم نقص
أتوقع أن فيتامين دال، النقص فيه غريب في المنطقة عندنا في الخليج
لان احنا ما بنتعرّض للشمس كثير مع أن عندنا شمس كثير
بس يمكن لأن الشمس حادة عندنا ونمط الحياة ما يخليك تطلع؟ يمكن
بس في كل العالم فيه نقص فيتامين دال موجود
بسبب أسلوب الحياة الحديث اللي عادةً بيكون داخل المنازل
والسيارة وغيرها
طيب بالنسبة للحلقة فيه شيء معين
كان ودك نتكلم ما تكلمنا فيه؟
لا، أعتقد
كذا غطينا كل شيء؟
أيوة
شكرًا لك، الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لعمر الشنقيطي وأسيل با عبدالله في إعداد الحلقة
وخلف الكاميرات وهاب موسى
وفي التحرير محمد نور شمّت
وفي التلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
والتسجيل الصوتي والهندسة الصوتية عبدالعزيز المزي
ومنتج فنجان أيمن الحمّادي
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
طيب فيه أسئلة الجمهور، بسم الله
أنا أحسن أني أهتم مرة بالأمراض العصبية، بس أنها تخوفني
فأيش فيه أمراض غير الزهايمر؟
اللي ممكن واحد يصاب فيها؟
وأيش السلوكيات اللي في نمط حياة الواحد
هي اللي تخليها أقرب لأن يصاب بها؟
فيه «الباركنسنز» وحدة من الأمراض العصبية الحركية
بتشوف أنت بعض الناس بيكون تعابير وجههم ثابتة
عندهم رجفة بأيديهم، حركتهم روبوتية خفيفة أو بطيئة
هذا مرض «الباركنسنز»
ما في كثير أشياء بتقدر تعملها أنك تقي نفسك من «الباركنسنز»
غير أسلوب الحياة الصحي بشكل عام
بس بالنسبة للخرف كمان فيه بعض الأدلة بتشير
أن حمية «الكيتو» بتساعد بحماية الدماغ من تقدم الخرف
عجيب!
هو شيء مثير للاهتمام
ما بعرف قد إيه نسبة التأثير، بس فيه بعض الأدلة
مرة قريتها أتوقع أنها تغريدة أو شيء
لأن كل شوي يجيك ويقول لك
إذا أخذت مثلًا المحليات بدل السكر
أنها تزيد نسبة السرطان مثلًا، إذا ما أدري أيش بيزيد السرطان
فكثرة الأشياء، فيه أكل يجيب السرطان
فيه مشروبات تجيب السرطان وغيره
فكان يقول: أن كل إنسان نسبة تعرضه للسرطان 5% - 6% مثلًا
كل الناس، فأنت بيجيك بهذه النسبة
لو أخذت كل اللي يقولوا عليه هي يمكن تصير 5.5
بالضبط
ما يفرق صدق
بالضبط، وهذا الفرق بين الخطر المطلق والخطر النسبي
وهذا كثير بتشوفها بالإعلام
يصير يحكي لك مثلًا
تناول القهوة بيزيد نسبة إصابتك بسرطان الكذا بنسبة 50%
بس هذه النسبة النسبية أو الخطر النسبي
فعليًّا الخطر المطلق هو 0.1، صار 0.15
إيه
بالضبط
فيه شيء ثاني ما حكينا عنه بالزهايمر بالمناسبة
أنا حكيت ما في تدخلات طبيبة تمنع تدهوره
هو فيه تدخلات، أدوية معينة بتمنع شوي أو بتساعد شوي
فيه أدوية جديدة بتطلع الحين وبتساعد بشكل أكبر
بس أبغى أحكي هذا
أتوقع هو جيني صح؟
هو متعلق بالتقدم بالعمر بشكل كبير
فهو مبرمج فينا جينيًّا
يمكن شغلة ما حكينا عنها في الحلقة
هي عن أيش اللي يؤدي للتقدم في العمر؟
حكينا شوي عنها في الحلقة الماضيةـ بس ما حكينا عنها كثير
إذا ودك نحكي فيها؟
هي فيه نظرية اسمها نظرية فرط الوظيفة للشيخوخة
أو هي نظرية أن النمو اللي بيصير معنا
بيصير فينا خلال مرحلة الطفولة
نفس هذه العمليات تستمر ما بعد البلوغ
وهي اللي بتؤدي للتقدم في العمر
مثل السيارة اللي ماشية بشكل سريع على الطريق السريع
وبعدين تروح على طريق فرعي وبتكون ماشي بنفس السرعة
هذا هو التقدم في العمر
هذا الدافع الأساسي للتقدم في العمر
الحين العلماء بيبحثوا عن أدوية ممكن تبطئ هذه العملية
فهذا الشيء ممكن مستقبلًا يؤدي إلى أن ناخذ أدوية
بتبطئ كل عملية التقدم في العمر هذه
تقدم العمر أحس أنه مرة مشكلة
بس ممكن لو بدينا نستخدم التعديلات الجينية
وصارت متاحة ونسبة الأمان فيها عالية
أتوقع أنها بتحل معظم المشاكل وللا؟
هذه من التدخلات الطبية المستقبلية
اللي ممكن تحل العمر الجيني
أو خلنا نقول العمر الأقصى الجيني تبعنا
عمر الإنسان الأقصى تقريبًا 120 سنة جينيًّا
حتى لو عملت كل الأشياء الحياتية اللي حكينا عنها
وكنت مثالي 100% وعندك جينات رائعة جدًّا
ما راح تعيش أكثر من 120 سنة تقريبًا
فالشيء اللي راح يخلينا نتعدى هذا العمر الوحيد لحد الآن
اللي بنعتقد أنه ممكن يساعد هو التعديل الجيني
بس لساته في طور البحث المخبري
اللي هي مع «كريسبر» وغيره
ممكن إذا السرطان هو جينات تخرب، ويصير فيها عطب
فتروح تصلحها، وتنتهي المشكلة
إذا الخرف هو جينات، أنت جلست وتتبعتها
ولقيت أن هذه اللي لخبطتها
فتروح ترجعها وتعدلها
أحس معظم المشاكل حق الخرف بتنتهي
أيوة، بس الموضوع أعقد كثير من كذا
لأن التقنية اللي حكيت عنها «كريسبر» وغيرها
تقنيات التعديل الجيني
نقدر نستخدمها على خلية واحدة أو خليتين
بس مليارات الخلية في الجسم صعب نوصلها أصلًا
عشان نقدر نعدل الجينات تبعنا
ثاني شيء فهمنا للجينات ووظائفها مش كامل
احنا ما بنعرف بالضبط أيش الجينات اللي لازم نعدلها؟
وهل هذه التعديلات راح يكون لها أثار جانبية؟
لسه الفهم مش كامل لطريقة الوصول، ولطريقة التعديل
ولوظائف الجينات المتعلقة بالتقدم في العمر
فالموضوع معقد جدًّا لساتنا فهمنا فيه بسيط نوعًا ما، بس بيتطور
الله يعين يا رب
في هذه الحرمة الفرنسية اللي عمّرت عمرها 117 سنة
وكانت تدخن إلى أن ماتت يمكن وأكلها عادي
وهي أكثر واحدة معمرة
هذه من أكبر المغالطات
حبيبي!
اللي عند الناس لما نشوف المعمرين
أنه نشوف أسلوب حياتهم
فعليًّا الناس المعمرين اللي هم بيعيشوا أكثر من 100 سنة
عند النساء المعمرات، نسبة التدخين أعلى من المعدل الطبيعي
فمعناته التدخين صحي!
معناته التدخين صحي، صح؟
لا، بس لأن احنا بنشوف أسلوب الحياة
بس فعليًّا اللي بيخليهم يعمروا لهذه الدرجة
مش أسلوب الحياة تبعهم
كيف؟
جيناتهم، عندهم قابلية جينية للتعمير أعلى من الطبيعي
وعندهم حماية جينية كمان
عندهم جينات معينة بتحميهم من الأثار السلبية للتدخين
فهم بيعمروا
مو لنمط حياتهم إنما للجينات اللي عندهم
بيعمروا بالرغم من أسلوب حياتهم
مش بسبب أسلوب حياتهم
والله مشكلة
كنت أبغى أقول لك الأكل ونمط الحياة والحياة
هذا الكلام كله تقوله غير مهم
هذا للناس الطبيعية مثلي ومثلك
بس مش للناس اللي عندهم هذه الجينات
باقي شيء عندك أستاذ أيمن؟
أحس السلوكيات هي اللي تخليك أكثر عرضه للأمراضة العصبية
نمط الحياة، أيش نمط الحياة اللي يخليك أقرب لها؟
يمكن أكثر شيء: الخمول وعدم الحركة والوزن الزائد
هذه الأشياء يمكن أهم شيء بتؤدي
للمشاكل العصبية المتعلقة بالتقدم في العمر
سبحان الله، كيف الرياضة أحس أنها عنصر مهم في كل هذه التفاصيل
100%
شفت كيف يا وهاب، خليك في النادي
مبطل أصلًا
بطلت؟ ليش؟
أيش العلاقات؟ أعطيني سؤالك، أيش العلاقات؟
علاقاتك بطول العمر
فيه ناس كثيرة تقول: أن جودة علاقاتك
فيه وحدة من الدراسات الكبيرة اللي عُملت بـ«هارفرد»
على هذا الموضوع
وتتبعوا عدد كبير من الناس لفترة طويلة
وشافوا أن العلاقات الجيدة
وكانت علاقتها قوية مع طول العمر
بس هل الشيء صحيح؟
وللا هل الناس الصحيين اللي عمرهم طويل
هم اللي عندهم الوقت أن يكون عندهم علاقات جيدة؟
فيه دراسة ثانية على الهوايات مثلًا
ربطوا الهوايات بالتقدم في العمر والصحة
بس أعتقد أن الناس اللي صحتهم جيدة
بيقدروا يمارسوا هواياتهم
هي يمكن العلاقة عكسية تكون
ممكن، بس ممكن برضه اللي عنده علاقات سيئة
يكون عنده توتر عالي
أكيد فيه علاقة، بس قد إيه قوة هذه العلاقة
وقد إيه منها علاقة عكسية؟ ما بنعرف
فيه تغريدة لك مدري وين قاريها
اللي أن الواحد اللي ما عنده علاقات جيدة
كأنه يدخن خمسة عشر
لا، هذه كانت عن العزلة
أيوة، العزلة الاجتماعية أثارها السلبية سيئة جدًّا على الصحة
وللأسف هذا الشيء بيصير أكتر في المجتمعات الغربية
بس قاعد يزيد شوي في مجتمعاتنا
اللي هو أن الشخص يكون منعزل خاصة عند الكبار في السن
اللي يمكن ما عنده أولاد أو أولاده مسافرين أو كذا
ولحاله في بيت منعزل
ما عنده عمل، ما عنده أحد حواليه
هذا الشيء أثاره السلبية مثل التدخين ومشابه للتدخين
هذه آفة موجودة في العالم بشكل كبير